Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe 156. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, ich begrüße euch. Es geht weiter hier bei Chaos Radio Express. Letzten Wochen waren etwas unproduktiver aus verschiedenen Gründen, aber damit soll jetzt erstmal wieder Schluss sein. Ich hoffe, da kommt jetzt etwas in schnellerer Reihenfolge. Wir werden es sehen, keine Versprechungen, aber zumindest heute eine neue Folge. Und heute geht es mal wieder in außerirdische Bereiche, sozusagen, mal den Planeten mal wieder ein bisschen verlassen. Eigentlich nicht ganz so weit marschieren wie noch vor kurzem bei der Sendung Mikrokosmos, Makrokosmos, aber in gewisser Hinsicht passt das ganz gut dazu. Denn heute soll es ein wenig um das Sternensystem, und zwar nicht irgendein Sternensystem, sondern unser Sternensystem gehen. System Sol. Und dazu begrüße ich den Florian, Florian Freistetter. Hallo.
Hallo.
Im Netz, besser bekannt als Astrodicticum Simplex, viel mehr mit dem Blog Astrodicticum Simplex. Oder legst du dir diesen Namen auch schon selber irgendwie aufs Haupt?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Ich bleib bei Florian.
Du bist einfach der Florian. Okay. Da bin ich aber beruhigt, jetzt mit dem Namen anzusprechen. Was heißt denn das?
Astrodicticum Simplex, das ist eine Erfindung von Erhard Weigl. Erhard Weigl, das war hier so ein Ausjener, ich glaube im 16. Jahrhundert, ein Astronom und ein Lehrer an der Universität hier als Astronom, als Wissenschaftler, war er nicht sonderlich berühmt, also er hat jetzt nichts Großes entdeckt und nichts Wichtiges herausgefunden. Aber er war ein enorm guter Pädagoge, ein enorm guter Lehrer, der auch wirklich auch Pädagogik, Theorie betrieben hat und so weiter. Und als er die Vorlesungen an der Uni gemacht hat, die Studentenzahlen verdoppelt haben in Jena, und er hat ihm auch jede Menge Kram erfunden, also wirklich alle großen und kleinen Erfindungen. Sein Haus, das Weiglische Haus, gehört zu den sieben Wundern von Jena, gibt es aber leider nicht mehr, ist abgerissen worden. Es war voll mit technischen Spielereien, also irgendwie ein Fahrstuhl und ein Gerät, wo man auf einen Ende Wasser reingeleert hat und am anderen Ende kam Wein raus und so was. Und eines der Erfindungen hieß im Astrodeticum Simplex, das war ein Ding, dass man auf einen Sternen, also einen Himmelsglobus, draufgestanden hat. Dann konnte man auf dem Himmelsglobus mit einem Zeiger auf einen bestimmten Stern einstellen und da hat ein großer Zeiger auf dem Globus auf dem Himmel gezeigt, wo der Stern sich in echt befindet. Also so eine Art Laserpointer, der auf dem Stern gezeigt hat, wo die Menschen dann leichter den Stern finden konnten am Himmel.
Und das hat zufällig sich funktionieren?
Ich weiß es nicht. Es gibt noch ein Bild von so einem Gerät, in echt ist keins mehr vorhanden. Aber ich fand es dann einfach als Idee recht schön, vor allem in Bezug zu Jena, Bezug zur Astronomie, Bezug zur Wissensvermittlung, als Pädagoge Weigl und auch der Name, das heißt, das ist so Latein übersetzt, der einfache Sternenweiß oder der einfache Weißer zu den Sternen, was fürs Blog ganz gut passte. Und der Hauptgrund war, dass das Ding damals, glaube ich, drei Google-Hits hatte. Also das war noch überhaupt nicht belegt durch irgendwas, der Begriff, also habe ich mir genommen. In meinem Blog gibt es irgendwo einen Link, der heißt über das Blog und da wird das alles auch zusammen geschrieben, falls du das nachlesen willst.
Okay, ist schon so gut wie in den Wings vermerkt. Das heißt, du verstehst dein Blog so ein bisschen als Wegweiser zu den Sternen, aber es geht ja nicht nur um die Sterne.
Nein, es geht prinzipiell, geht es natürlich um Astronomie, weil das eben mein Beruf ist und das uns interessiert. Aber in meinem Blog spreche ich eigentlich über alles, was mich jetzt so interessiert. Es geht nicht nur um Astronomie, es geht um Wissenschaft im Allgemeinen, also auch Physik und andere Naturwissenschaften. Es geht auch um Wissenschaftsvermittlung, um Wissenschaftspolitik. Es geht um die Dinge, die der Wissenschaftsvermittlung im Wege stehen, also die ganze Pseudowissenschaft, Esoterik, Astrologie und der ganze Komplex, was es da gibt. Es sind oft andere private Sachen drin. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich mit dem Fahrrad noch die Gegend fahre, muss schon jeder ein Foto davon machen. Also es ist im Prinzip ein Blog über mich und die Wissenschaft.
Weil es doch recht viel Hall hat. Mal kurz mal gucken, ob ich hier ein bisschen... Das Blog ist ja Bestandteil von einer ganzen Serie von Blogs, den Science-Blogs. Was hat es damit auf sich?
Also die Science-Blogs stammen ursprünglich aus Amerika. Da gibt es den Seed-Verlag. Die bringen uns eine Wissenschaftszeitschaft heraus und die haben halt, ich weiß nicht genau, wann das angefangen hat, aber haben so ein Blogportal aufgemacht und dort Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftsjournalisten eingeladen, um über ihre Arbeit und über das zu schreiben, was sie machen, was sie interessiert. Und das Konzept ist eben extrem erfolgreich. Also die Scienceblogs in Amerika sind, gehören zu den bekanntesten und beliebtesten Wissenschaftsblogs überhaupt. Und Ende 2008, nee Ende 2007, 2008 hat es dann ein deutscher Verlag übernommen, das Konzept. Und auch hier mit der deutschen Version von Scienceblogs gestartet und da wurden eben auch einige deutsche Wissenschaftler eingeladen, unter anderem ich. Mittlerweile gibt es sogar, glaube ich, eine brasilianische Scienceblog-Seite, die in portugiesisch gebloggt wird. Und soweit ich weiß, ist auch geplant, das noch in weiteren Sprachen zu erweitern. Aber es ist eben dieses Scienceblogs-Konzept, das ich recht gut und recht ansprechend finde. Weil man wirklich nicht isoliert mit seinem Blog. Da steht es dann auch im größeren Kontext mit vielen anderen wissenschaftlichen Disziplinen präsentiert und gelesen wird.
Und wie erfolgreich ist das Ganze so in Deutschland? Hat das dann schon ganz schön aufschließen zu der amerikanischen Popularität oder spielt Wissenschaft hier in Deutschland so ein bisschen deutschsprachigen Raum vielmehr eine andere Rolle?
Was die Wissenschaftsblogs angeht, würde ich sagen, dass die Deutschland doch noch hinter Amerika zurück ist. Also da haben die Blogs schon noch einen größeren Stellenband. Ich glaube, es ist nicht nur auf Wissenschaftsblogs bezogen, sondern generell auf die ganze Blog-Szene, die in Deutschland doch nicht ganz so etabliert ist, wie es in Amerika ist. Also da ist sicher noch ein bisschen Aufholbedarf.
Meinst du, das liegt wirklich am Blog als solchen? Oder liegt es am Thema Wissenschaft?
Das ist schwer zu beantworten. Ich bin jetzt kein Experte, was Blog-Szene und Web 2.0 und den ganzen Kram angeht. Also vielleicht mal ein Medienwissenschaftler fragen, was er dazu sagt. Aber mir kommt schon so vor, dass das in Deutschland eher noch die Blogs halt als so eine Art, ja, was Leute so zusammen schreiben im Netz angesehen wird und nicht als verlässliche Nachrichtenquelle, wie irgendwelche Zeitungen oder Online-Zeitungen oder sowas. Obwohl im Prinzip bei Online-Zeitungen selten Experten sitzen, die Wissenschaftsnachrichten schreiben und bei den Blogs aber schon. Also insofern könnte man die Blogs als verlässlichere Quelle ansehen, was sie auch oft auch sind. Aber es fehlt so, die Akzeptanz ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig da, würde ich sagen.
Kommt Zeit, kommt Rat, das Problem haben die Podcasts natürlich genauso. Bevor wir uns auf die Reise begeben, würde ich gerne noch mal was aufgreifen, was du gerade gesagt hast, dass du dich eben auch so mit den Pseudo-Wissenschaften so ein bisschen rumärgerst. Das liest man ja so zwischen den Zeilen bzw. bisweilen auch direkt in den Artikeln, die du schreibst. Warum ist dir das so wichtig? Warum zielst du darauf? Warum beschäftigst du dich da überhaupt mit? Kann man das nicht einfach nur ignorieren?
Natürlich kann man es ignorieren. Man kann alles ignorieren. Aber der Grund, warum ich einen Blog schreibe, ist, dass ich den Menschen zeigen will, wie schön, wie spannend, wie faszinierend die Wissenschaft ist. Einfach Wissenschaftsvermittlung, Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Ich glaube gerade, dass in einer Disziplin wie Astronomie, die eigentlich nur Grundlagenforschung ist, wo die selten, im Vergleich zu Medizin oder Technik oder Biologie, Dinge produziert, die der Mensch im Alltagsleben im Supermarkt sieht oder so was, oder in der Apotheke, das haben die Astronomen nicht. Das, was wir machen, ist Grundlagenforschung, relativ extrakt. Und gerade da denke ich, ist es wichtig, dass man den Menschen eben auch zeigt, was man macht, weil man das im normalen Alltag nicht mitbekommt. Ich denke, dass es wichtig ist, dem Menschen zu zeigen, warum wir Astronomen das machen, was wir machen, und warum das wichtig ist, dass wir das machen, warum es interessant ist, warum es faszinierend ist. Und wenn man den Menschen zeigen will, warum Wissenschaft wichtig und spannend ist, dann muss man ihm auch zeigen, was Wissenschaft nicht ist und was dieser Wissenschaft entgegensteht. Die Esoterik, die Pseudowissenschaft, die sind extrem populär in der Gesellschaft. Da braucht man in einen beliebigen Buchladen gehen. Da reicht es auch schon, wenn man eine Zeitung liest, alles voll mit Horoskopen und Kartenlegern und Orakeln. Das sind alles Sachen, die einem wirklich guten Verständnis von Wissenschaft entgegenstehen. Die Grundprinzipien der Esoterik sind diametral entgegengesetzt in den Grundprinzipien der Wissenschaftlichkeit. Wenn man den Menschen zeigen will, wie interessant Wissenschaft ist, dann muss man auch sagen, was keine Wissenschaft ist. Man darf das nicht ignorieren, sondern muss das genau aufzeigen. Das ist meine Meinung dazu. Sonst macht es keiner. Die Wissenschaft hat fast keine Lobby vergleichbar mit anderen Disziplinen. Wenn die Wissenschaftler sich selbst um ihre Dinge kümmern, dann macht es keiner. Wenn man nicht will, dass immer mehr Menschen an unwissenschaftlichen Unsinn glauben, dann müssen die Wissenschaftler sich selbst darum kümmern.
Schauen wir mal, was wir dazu beitragen können. Du bist Astronom, voll ausgebildet, diplomiert und bedoktert. Was macht denn der Astronom?
Der macht...
Ist ja ein alter, erwürdiger Beruf. Man könnte ja fast sagen, es gehört wahrscheinlich zu den ältesten wissenschaftlichen Disziplinen überhaupt, in die Sterne zu schauen, oder?
Ja, also wenn man in die Sterne schaut, kann man sagen, das gehört zu den ältesten Tätigkeiten. Wissenschaft wurde es erst später irgendwann, als mit Galileo dann generell sich die Naturwissenschaften gebildet haben.
Damals gab es ja auch noch kein Internet, wo sollte man auch sonst hingucken?
Nee, aber ein Astronom macht viele verschiedene Dinge. Es hängt davon ab, welches Spezialgebiet man hat. Also es ist nicht mehr so wie früher, wo quasi jeder Astronom durchs Teleskop geschaut hat, nächtelang. Heutzutage sitzt eigentlich fast jeder Astronom, sitzt auch wie die meisten anderen Menschen auf dem Schreibbisch vom Computer. Und die beobachtenden Astronomen natürlich gehen dann auch ans Teleskop und beobachten auch in der Nacht, auch wenn sie nicht mehr wirklich selbst durchschauen, sondern das macht auch alles Kameras und Computer. Aber normalerweise ist es so, dass auch die beobachtenden Astronomen, die fahren dann halt ein paar Mal im Jahr, fahren die halt irgendwo zu irgendwelchen Sternen warten und beobachten dort. Aber der Großteil der Arbeit spielt sich wirklich am Computer ab. Und je nachdem, was man da macht, beschäftigt man sich mit Galaxien, mit Planeten, mit Sternen, man beschäftigt sich mit theoretischen Modellen, man schreibt Computer-Programme, man überlegt sich, wie man vielleicht neue Instrumente baut, man überlegt sich vielleicht auch rein nur mathematische Sachen. Also es gibt Astronomen, deren Arbeit sich kaum von der Arbeit von der Mathematik unterscheidet. Es gibt Astronomen, deren Arbeit unterscheidet sich kaum von der eines Technikers oder Ingenieurs, je nachdem, was man halt für ein Spezialgebiet sich ausgesucht hat.
Was ist dein Spezialgebiet?
Ich bin Himmelsmechaniker, das heißt, ich beschäftige mich mit der Bewegung der Himmelskörper. Und in meinem Fall sind das speziell die Bewegungen von Asteroiden und von Planeten.
Ja, damit wären wir ja quasi schon beim Thema angelangt. Ich habe es ja schon erwähnt, bin hier schon einmal durch den ganzen Kosmos und Urknall durchmarschiert. Das war auch eine etwas ausführlichere Sendung. Allerdings war das dann irgendwie so viel, dass dann den konkreten Blick auf das, was man unmittelbar hier so wahrnehmen kann, sprich unser eigenes Sternensystem, gar nicht so sehr in den Fokus kam. Und naja, da kennst du dich ja ein bisschen aus. Da wollte ich mal so ein bisschen nachhaken. Wenn man mal so ein bisschen in die eigentliche Geschichte der Himmelsbeobachtung zurückschaut, ich weiß nicht, wann ging das irgendwie so richtig los? Ich meine, es ist immer so eine Frage. Los ging es wahrscheinlich, seit es Menschen gab, und sie irgendwie einen klaren Gedanken fassen konnten. Aber so Aufzeichnungen und wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse sind von den Griechen.
Ja, auch schon früher, also schon Ägypten, Babylonier, Mesopotamien ist es da, gab es schon Aufzeichnungen und auch Berechnungen von, wie sich die Planeten bewegen, wie die Wand Sonnenfinsternisse gibt und so, das gab es schon relativ lange.
Und welche Erkenntnisse wurden zu diesem Zeitpunkt bereits gezogen?
Also damals wusste man, man unterschied zum Beispiel auf jeden Fall schon mal die Sterne von den Planeten. Also man wusste, dass es da eben Objekte gibt, die sich im Vergleich zu den Sternen viel schneller bewegen am Himmel. Und man konnte auch deren Bewegung berechnen, man konnte deren Bewegung am Himmel halbwegs vorhersagen, also innerhalb von gewissen Genauigkeitsgrenzen, die halt damals viel schlechter waren als heute, aber eben es ging. Man konnte vorhersagen, wann der Sonnenfinstern, also der Mondfinstern stattfinden wird. Also das alles war möglich. Später bei den Griechen dann konnte man auch erste physikalische Sachen, physikalische Erkenntnisse über den Kosmos gewinnen. Also man fand heraus, dass Erde und Mond rund sind, Sonne ist rund, dass es Kugeln sind. Man konnte ungefähr ein bisschen abschätzen, wie groß die Erde ist, wie groß die Sonne ist, wie groß der Mond ist. Also das waren so erste Ergebnisse, die man damals gewonnen hat. Aber so richtig los, wissenschaftlichen Sinne ging es dann erst viel später, also mit Galileo Galilei kann man sagen, als die ersten Teleskope dann mit der Astronomie verwendet wurden. Damals fing dann die Astronomie eigentlich, so wie sie heute durchgeführt wird, erst so richtig an.
Da gibt es ja auch so diese dunkle Zeit, wo dieser Glaube, wie sozusagen, dass die Erde sich um die Sonne dreht und nicht anders herum im Prinzip von der Beobachtung her und von den wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen her eigentlich lange feststand, aber so nie akzeptiert wurde.
Na ja, es war einfach so, dass bis zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, wenn man die Zeit vor Galileo hernimmt, von den Griechen bis der Galileo ungefähr, dann gab es einfach gewisse Beobachtungen und die Beobachtungen konnten noch verschiedener Art und Weise interpretiert werden. Also wenn wir jetzt aus dem Fenster schauen, sehen wir, dass die Sonne aufgeht, die Sonne geht unter, die Sonne bewegt sich in den Himmel. Das sieht für uns so aus, als würde die Sonne sich um die Erde bewegen. Und es gibt noch andere Beobachtungen, die man da machen kann. Und die sind vereinbar mit dem Weltbild, dass die Erde im Zentrum steht und sich die Sonne rundherum dreht. Man kann das natürlich genauso interpretieren, als die Sonne steht im Zentrum und die Erde bewegt sich rundherum. Das waren quasi zwei damals gleichwertige Sichtweisen, gleichwertige Interpretationen für dieselbe Beobachtung. Und es war lange Zeit nicht wirklich von den Beobachtungsdaten her wirklich konkret zu unterscheiden, welcher ist richtig, welcher ist falsch. Es wurde dann auch als Ausgehend von den alten Griechen das geozentrische Weltbild von der Kirche her als Dogma festgesetzt. Die haben gemeint, das muss eben so sein. Die haben einfach gesagt, das ist richtig. Das ist so, obwohl es jetzt von der Beobachtungsseite her genauso gut anders sein hätte können. Aber damals hat man gesagt, okay, es ist einfach von gesundem Menschheitsverstand her. Wir sehen, dass die Erde sich nicht dreht. Wenn die Erde sich irgendwie drehen würde, dann würden wir spüren, dann würde der Fahrtwind uns um die Nase wehen und so weiter. Das hat man damals eben so aufgefasst. Das ist jetzt das, was vernünftig ist und das ist das, was richtig ist. Und eigentlich war es dann erst mit Galileo Galilei, als der mit seinem Fernrohr die Venus beobachtet hat, dass man wirklich als die konkrete Beobachtungsergebnisse hatte, die ihm zeigten, dass die Erde sich um die Sonne dreht. Weil man kann, wenn man die Venus von der Erde aus gesehen zeigt, auch Phasen wie der Mond. Also es gibt Vollvenus und Halbvenus und sowas in der Art. Und man kann zeigen, dass je nachdem, ob jetzt die Erde sich um die Sonne dreht oder die Sonne um die Erde dreht, und je nachdem, wo jetzt die Venus sich rumdreht, ob die sich auch um die Erde dreht oder um die Sonne dreht, dass dann diese Venus-Phasen leicht unterschiedlich ausfallen würden. Und das konnte dann eben Galileo mit seinem Teleskop beobachten, diese Venus-Phasen und hat dann wirklich gesehen, okay, die sind genauso, wie es sein muss, wenn die Erde sich um die Sonne dreht. Es war zwar immer noch nicht der absolut hundertprozentige, letztgültige Beweis, dass man hätte sich noch andere Modelle ausdenken können, wie jetzt die Erde, die Sonne sich doch noch um die Erde drehen könnte, dass es irgendwie hinhaut. Aber im Prinzip war damals diese Entwicklung von Galileo vor 401 Jahren. Letztes Jahr haben wir die 400-Jahr-Feier gefeiert. Also vor 401 Jahren hat Galileo quasi mit dieser Beobachtung das Ende des geozentrischen Weltbilds eingeleutet.
Das heißt, dann hat es auch noch dem Letzten eingeleuchtet?
Ja, das hat schon noch ein bisschen gedauert. Es musste noch Copernicus und seine Arbeit akzeptiert werden. Dann kam noch Kepler, der noch mal die Bewegung der Himmelskörper gezeigt hat. Denn es war damals auch so, dass man auch berechnen wollte, wie bewegen sich die Himmelskörper. Man konnte die Berechnungen sowohl mit dem geozentrischen Weltbild als auch mit dem heliozentrischen Weltbild durchführen. Es hat beides in gewissen Grenzen funktioniert. Kepler hat dann gezeigt durch seine keplerschen Gesetze und durch die Erkenntnis, dass die Planeten und Himmelskörper sich nicht auf Kreisen bewegen, sondern auf Ellipsen, und dass sie unterschiedlich schnell sich um die Sonne bewegen. Erst durch diese Erkenntnisse hat dem Kepler gezeigt, dass das heliozentrische Weltbild wirklich bessere und genauere Vorhersagen liefert als das geozentrische Weltbild.
Das heißt, Kepler war dann im Prinzip der eigentliche Durchbruch?
Ich glaube, man kann es nicht so als den eigentlichen Durchbruch ansehen. Das war so eine sukzessive Abfolge von immer neuen Erkenntnissen, bis das dann wirklich...
Aber im Prinzip hat er also die Daten geliefert, die jetzt wirklich dann auch die letzte Erklärung für, wie unser Sternensystem jetzt konkret abläuft, gedient hat.
Ach naja, wie würdest du sagen, das hat dann noch lange gedauert. Nach Kepler kam dann noch Newton, der die Gravitationsgesetze gebracht hat. Da musste man wirklich nach welchen Gesetzemäßigkeiten sich die Planeten bewegen. Das wusste man ja von Kepler nicht. Kepler hat zwar seine Kepler-Gesetze aufgestellt, die ein paar grundlegende Eigenschaften der Bewegung erklären, aber er konnte die dahinter liegende Kraft nicht beschreiben.
Also er wusste nicht warum, aber er wusste, so muss es sein.
Ja, warum wusste Newton nicht auch nicht, aber Newton konnte genau erklären, welche Gesetzemäßigkeit dahinter steckt. Und eigentlich, wenn Kepler ein bisschen Glück gehabt hätte, dann hätte er es auch schaffen können. Also man kann das Gravitationsgesetz aus den Keplerschen Gesetzen ableiten. Also wenn Kepler ein bisschen noch einen kleinen weiteren Kreisenspitz gehabt hätte, dann hätte er vielleicht die Erdes Gravitationsgesetz entdeckt. Aber bis halt auch Newton mache ich das Ende. Also das hat dann ja noch lange gedauert, bis eigentlich bis Ende, also bis Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts, bis Albert Einstein dann seine allgemeine Realitätstheorie aufgestellt hat, mit der dann quasi das letzte ausstehende, das bisherige letzte ausstehende Rätsel gelöst werden konnte, konnte eben die Bewegung von Merkur, die man auch mit Newtons Gesetz nicht erklären konnte.
Warum nicht?
Das war damals das Problem, dass man halt, man hat beobachtet, wo Merkur sich befindet. Man konnte ihm genau immer zeigen, an welchen Positionen Merkur sich befindet auf dem Lauf um die Sonne. Und man hat eben auch berechnen können, ja klar, mit Newtons Gravitation Gesetz konnte man ausrechnen, wo Merkur sich am Himmel befindet. Das Problem war, dass es da eben einen Unterschied gab. Dass man ausgerechnet hat, hat nicht mit dem eingestimmt, was man beobachtet hat. Und das ist natürlich immer zu erwarten. Man macht immer Fehler bei der Beobachtung. Hundertprozentig übereinstimmen wird es nie. Aber die Fehler waren eben so groß, dass man es nicht allein durch die Beobachtungsungenauigkeiten erklären konnte. Die Möglichkeiten, die es gab, waren entweder, dass das Newton-Gesetz falsch ist, dass die Gravitation nicht richtig beschreibt, oder dass da irgendwo in der Nähe von Merkur noch was ist, was wir nicht kennen und was die Bewegung von Merkur beeinflusst. Also in dem Fall einfach ein weiterer Planet, also noch ein Planet innerhalb der Merkur-Bahn, der damals Vulkan genannt wurde. Und wenn der da gewesen wäre, dann hätte eben dessen Kraft, die wir nicht berücksichtigt haben, weil wir nicht kennen, die Bahn des Merkurs beeinflusst. Man hat damals wirklich lange geglaubt, dass es diesen Vulkan gibt, denn da gab es den großen französischen Himmelsmechaniker Urban Leverrier, der damals schon das gleiche Problem gelöst hat, das bei Uranus aufgetreten ist. Also es gab bei Uranus das gleiche Problem wie bei Merkur. Auch Uranus hat sich nicht so bewegt, wie man es voraus berechnet hat. Und auch damals hat man schon überlegt, okay, vielleicht stimmt Newton nicht. Aber Urban Leverrier hat gesagt, nee, Newton, das Gesetz muss stimmen, das ist in Ordnung. Da gibt es doch irgendwo einen Planeten, der die Bahn des Uranus stört. Und hat dann eben mit ziemlich mühsamen und langwierigen Rechnungen, damals gab es ja keine Computer oder so was, hat dann eben ausgerechnet, welche Eigenschaften es zum Planeten haben müsste, damit er genau die beobachteten Abweichungen bei Uranus erzeugt. Und hat sich damals ein richtiges Duell geliefert mit John Couch Adams, der war quasi Leverriers Gegenspieler in England und England und Frankreich haben es ja nie, sondern ich mögen damals zumindestens. Es gab wirklich, also da in den Zeitungen haben sich die Journalisten, wirklich das war so, es nahe wie heute jetzt bei der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft, die Zeitungen schreiben, ob jetzt irgendwie das England gewinnt oder Frankreich gewinnt, also war das damals die Wissenschaft, ja. Also da haben die Menschen wirklich spekuliert, wer schafft jetzt jetzt, wer findet es erst den Planeten, findet es Adams aus England oder findet es Leverriers aus Frankreich? Also das war was, da wo die Menschen damals wirklich darüber gesprochen haben, was für ein Thema.
So wie mit den Russen und den Amerikanern und dem Mond?
So ungefähr, ja. Also dann haben wirklich, beide haben gerechnet, beide haben ihre Beobachter gehabt, die probiert haben, das zu finden und Leverrier hat da eben das bisschen Glück gehabt und hat seine Beobachtungen dann an Gottfried Galle in Berlin geschickt und der hat eben wirklich nur das Teleskop ausgerichtet durchgeschaut und im Prinzip mehr oder weniger sofort diesen neuen Planeten gefunden, der dann eben Neptun war. Und weil ihm das damals so erfolgreich war, also wirklich dieser Triumph der Himmelsmechanik, der Triumph des Newton-Gesetzes, dass eben wirklich das Gesetz so gut ist, dass man einen neuen Planeten damit entdecken kann, ohne dass man quasi durch das Teleskop schaut, rein nur vom Rechnen her.
Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden, also diese Logik. Also er hatte welche Erkenntnisse, die ihn dann auf die Spur gebracht haben, also was genau hat ihn vermuten lassen, dass da noch ein Planeten sein müsste?
Ja, du hast, wenn du die Bewegung eines Planeten berechnen willst, dann hängt die Bewegung von der Gravitationskraft ab. Also die Sonne zieht an den Planeten und alle anderen Planeten beeinflussen die Planeten auch. Genau. Und ich kann jetzt, wenn ich jetzt ausrechnen will, wo ist der Planet morgen, dann schaue ich jetzt beim Himmel nach dem Teleskop, heute ist er da, dann sage ich okay, ich habe Gravitationskraft von der Sonne, von Merkowin aus Erde, Mars, Jupiter und Saturn und rechne das alles aus und dann weiß ich okay, die Gesamtkraft auf Uranus ist die und die und morgen wird er da sein. Dann kann ich morgen nachschauen, ob das so ist. Wenn ich jetzt feststelle, das ist nicht so, dann habe ich irgendwo unterwegs einen Fehler gemacht. Entweder mein Fehler war, ich habe das falsche Gesetz verwendet, das heißt, die Gravitationstheorie ist falsch. Oder ich habe nicht alle Einflüsse bröchselt. Ich habe gerade gesagt, wir haben genommen Sonne, Merkowin aus Erde, Mars, Jupiter, Saturn. Das waren damals alle bekannten Himmelskörper. Und wenn da jetzt noch ein Himmelskörper ist, ein Unbekannter, dann hat der auch einen Einfluss. Aber wenn ich nicht weiß, dass es einen Himmelskörper gibt, einen unbekannten, dann kann ich den Einfluss nicht berücksichtigen. Dann fehlt mir irgendwas in meiner Gleichung. Und die zwei Möglichkeiten waren eben, entweder die Gleichung ist falsch oder es gibt noch einen Planeten. Genau. Und Leberier war überzeugt davon, dass die Gleichung richtig ist, das Newtonische Gravitationsgesetz und dass es ihm noch so einen unbekannten Planeten geben muss. Und er hat dann probiert herauszufinden, welche Eigenschaften muss ein Planeten haben, damit er genau diese Abweichung erzeugt.
Das heißt, er hat im Prinzip auch schon die Größe, die Masse dieses Planeten auch gleich mitbestimmt.
Genau, ja. Also es waren natürlich Ungenauigkeiten. Wie ich gesagt habe, Leberier hat Glück gehabt, dass seine Vorhersage ziemlich genau übereingestimmt hat. Sie war nicht ganz exakt, aber er hat ein bisschen Glück gehabt, dass es trotzdem hingekommen ist.
Wann war das ungefähr?
Oh Gott, Jahreszahlen, die weiß ich alle nicht mehr auswendig. Es müsste so eine Neptunsentdeckung 1848 gewesen sein, glaube ich. Bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber irgendwie so um den Dreh rum.
Ich gucke mal. Aber mit anderen Worten, keine Computer und überhaupt auch noch eine ganze Menge sonstige Erkenntnisse nicht gehabt.
Schon erstaunlich. Es war sehr erfolgreich, dass dieser Triumph der Himmelsmechanik 1846 war. Man war davon überzeugt, dass sich die Abweichung der Merkur-Bahn sich genauso erklären lässt. Dass es noch einen weiteren Planeten gibt innerhalb der Merkur-Bahn, der diesen Unterschied zwischen Theorie und Beobachtung der Merkur erzeugt. Man hat ihn wirklich jahrelang gesucht, jahrzehntelang fast gesucht nach diesem Vulkan, der wirklich schwer zu beobachten ist. Wenn er so nah an der Sonne steht, dann kann man ihn eigentlich in der Nacht nicht beobachten. Weil in der Nacht ist die Sonne nicht da. Und wenn der Planet nahe bei der Sonne ist, dann geht er auch mit der Sonne unter, geht mit der Sonne auf. Das heißt, man kann ihn eigentlich in der Nacht nicht beobachten, weil er dann nicht am Himmel steht. Das heißt, man musste entweder die Sonne selbst beobachten, also mit Filtern und der Tag die Sonne beobachten, und schauen vielleicht, ob man vor der Sonnenscheibe so ein bisschen was, so ein kleines Pünktchen vorüberziehen sieht, was natürlich auch genauso gut ein Sonnenfleck sein kann oder ein Vogel oder sonst irgendwas. Ja, also da gab es jede Menge Fehler. Und wenn man lange irgendwie mit Teleskop, selbst mit Filter, auf die Sonne startet, dann sieht man sowieso jede Menge komische Sachen. Das heißt, es gab da sehr viele Sichtungen dieses Vulkans. Es gab viele Menschen, die Astronomen, die den Vulkan gesehen haben, die sich aber dann nie bestätigen lassen. Das wurde nie bestätigt, diese Beobachtungen. Man hat dann auch zu Sonnenfinsternissen, ja, wo die Sonne verfinstert ist, dann kann man ja besonders gut sehen, was da in der Nähe ist. Es gab solche Expeditionen überall in alle Welteile, um diesen Vulkan zu finden, hat aber auch nie geklappt. Und man hat ja nicht erst dann aufgehört zu suchen, als eben dann Albert Einstein 1915 gezeigt hat, das ist eine allgemeine Repetitstheorie, dass eben in dem Fall die andere Lösung die richtige ist. Also kein unbekannter Einfluss, sondern das falsche Gesetz. In dem Fall war eben das Newton-Schall Gravitationsgesetz nicht gut genug, um die Bewegung von Merck kurz zu erklären, nicht genau genug. Und man braucht eben Einsteins allgemeine Repetitstheorie, mit der lässt sich dann die Bewegung von Merck-Hur wirklich so exakt vorhersagen, dass man nicht mehr nach einem unbekannten Planeten suchen muss.
Was war denn der jetzt konkrete Einfluss, den man da sozusagen berücksichtigen muss?
Bei der allgemeinen Repetitstheorie hängt, sagt er, das Massen-krümelnden Raum. Und Merck-Hur ist das eine nächste Planet, der ist quasi an der Sonne ganz nah dran. Und wenn man da, da ist die Raumkrümelung am stärksten, je näher man an die Sonne kommt. Das heißt, bei den anderen Planeten ist dieser Effekt der Raumkrümelung auf die Bewegung, der ist eben vernachlässigbar bekommen. Ja, den merkt man nicht. Die Beobachtungsfehler sind da viel größer. Aber weil Merck-Hur eben so nah dran ist, merkt man das dann da viel stärker. Und da hat eben das Newton-Gesetz, dass er quasi nur eine Annäherung ist an die Repetitstheorie, eben war die Annäherung zu ungenau. Da hat man wirklich die exakten Formeln gebraucht.
Machen wir doch mal so ein bisschen mehr Sendung mit der Maus. Und passen wir mal die ganze Familie zusammen. Ich wollte mich ja jetzt hier mal konkret auf unser Sonnensystem konzentrieren, was ja allgemein bekannt sein dürfte. Wir sind bald nicht das einzige Sternensystem, sondern ich glaube, die Zahl lässt sich auch überhaupt gar nicht bestimmen. Oder gibt es da irgendeine Schätzung?
Wie viele Planeten es gibt? Wie viele Sternensysteme? Das Sternensystem ist eigentlich ein Ausdruck, den man eher für Milchstraßen benutzt, also für Galaxien, also ein System, bestehend aus Sternen. Das ist quasi eine Galaxie, besteht aus vielen Sternen. Wenn du jetzt meinst, ein System wie unser Sonnensystem, also ein Stern mit Planeten rundherum, dann sagt man dazu eher Sonnensystem oder Planetensystem. Das heißt also, in unserer Galaxie gibt es, wie viel soll es da geben, so ein paar 100 Milliarden Sternen ungefähr. Also genau kann man es jetzt nicht wirklich abschätzen, aber so ungefähr 100 Milliarden Sterne in unserer Galaxie kommt ungefähr hin. Und im ganzen Universum gibt es vielleicht noch mal ein paar 100 Milliarden Galaxien.
Also kann man sich ausrechnen, sind auf die ganze Menge.
Und also wie viele Planeten es dann noch gibt, kann man auch nicht sagen. Man weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie viele Sterne Planeten haben, aber es werden auf jeden Fall nicht wenige sein. Wir kennen jetzt mittlerweile schon fast 500 Planeten um andere Sterne. Und wir haben gerade erst mal angefangen zu suchen.
Aber wovon geht man denn aus? Geht man davon aus, dass eigentlich jeder Stern irgendwelche Planeten hat oder ist das die Ausnahme?
Eigentlich nicht. Im Prinzip geht man davon aus, dass nach unseren aktuellen Modellen, wie ein Stern entsteht, der entsteht ja aus einer großen Wolke mit Gas und Staub und die verdichtet sich, der zentrale Bereich wird immer dichter und dichter, bis er irgendwann so dicht wird, dass der Druck und die Temperatur im inneren dieses dichten Bereichs so hoch werden, dass Kernfusion einsetzen kann. Und dann habe ich einen Stern. Und dann hängt es davon ab, ob der Stern bei seiner Entstehung das ganze Material, was um ihn herum war, aufgebraucht hat oder nicht. Wenn was übrig geblieben ist, dann kann aus dem übrig gebliebenen Zeug Planeten entstehen. Wenn der alles aufgebraucht hat, dann nicht. Und man geht eigentlich schon davon aus, dass es je nachdem, welche Art von Sternen man betrachtet, es gibt ja verschiedene Typen von Sternen, sehr große, sehr heiße, sehr kleine, die weniger heiß sind. Also je nach Art von Sternen, also bei Sternen wie unsere Sonne zum Beispiel, dass da jetzt Planeten, sagen wir mal, zumindest nichts außergewöhnliches sind. Ob sie jetzt wirklich häufig sind, das weiß man noch nicht genau. Dazu haben wir noch zu wenig Beobachtungsdaten. Im Moment können wir, wir können noch nicht alle Planeten beobachten, die da sind. Also selbst wenn wir jetzt ein System beobachten, das Planeten hat, dann können wir davon nur die ganz Großen sehen. Diese Großen wie Jupiter zum Beispiel. Oder auch ein bisschen kleiner. Die Techniken werden immer besser und besser. Aber so Planeten, so klein wie unsere Erde zum Beispiel, die können wir noch nicht oder nur extrem schwer beobachten im Moment. Das wird sich ändern in den nächsten, sagen wir mal, zehn Jahren ungefähr. Da haben wir neue Missionen im Weltraum, Systemmissionen. Es sind jetzt zum Beispiel schon welche unterwegs wie KORO oder Kepler, die schon wahnsinnig viel entdeckt haben. KORO hat jetzt vor kurzem erst acht neue Planeten gefunden. KORO schreibt sich C-O-R-O-T, ist eine Mission der Europäischen Raumfahrt-Agentur. Und Kepler ist eine Mission der NASA und die haben auch vor kurzem die Entdeckung von 500 Planetenkandidaten bekannt gegeben. Die Missionen werden einiges finden und dann soll in ein paar Jahren Gaia starten. Die Mission, da sollen ein paar Tausend, Zehntausend Planeten entdeckt werden. Ich denke, in zehn Jahren ungefähr werden wir wirklich einen guten Überblick haben, wie häufig Planeten um andere Sterne sind.
Okay, war da jetzt eigentlich die Antwort drin? Also ist es eher die Ausnahme? Kann man das so festhalten, dass so viele Planeten sich um eine Sonne scharen?
Also die Antwort war insofern drinnen, dass man noch nicht sagen kann, ob es eine Ausnahme ist oder nicht. Wir wissen, dass es Planeten gibt um andere Sterne. Wir wissen, dass es auch Systeme gibt, wo mehrere Planeten einen Stern umkreisen. Aber da wir noch nicht fähig sind, alle Planeten zu entdecken, die um einen Stern kreisen, können wir noch nicht genau sagen, ob es eine Ausnahme ist oder nicht. Aber nach allem, was wir jetzt wissen, von der Theorie her, sollte man eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass unser Sonnensystem nichts außergewöhnliches ist.
Wir sind einfach, wie Douglas Adams mal so schön gesagt hat, in einem langweiligen, wie gesagt, total aus der Mode gekommenen Spiralarm.
Langweilig würde ich es nicht nennen, unser Sonnensystem. Vermutlich nichts Außergewöhnliches.
Okay, also man kann davon ausgehen, dass wir jetzt beileibe nicht die Einzigen sind, so in der Form. Aber es ist auch nicht so, dass jetzt jeder Stern einen ganzen Trossplaneten um sich herum mit sich führt. Wahrscheinlich.
Genau, ja.
Okay. Ja, jetzt haben wir ja schon das eine oder andere wiedergegeben. Das ist ja auch schon so ein bisschen Allgemeinbildung, aber ich glaube, auch Allgemeinbildung muss manchmal wiederholt werden. Was haben wir denn jetzt sozusagen in unserem Sternensystem? Was wissen wir? Wenn man mal von der Sonne startet. Und ja, was wir schon erwähnt haben, der erste ist wahrscheinlich der Merkur.
Wenn du jetzt von den Planeten ausgehst, ja, dann...
Ich meine, auch wenn da was anderes Interessantes ist. Also wenn jetzt von der Sonne oder fangen wir doch mal mit der Sonne an.
Genau, das kommt davon, was man jetzt...
Ich denke, wir müssen einfach bei der Sonne anfangen. Also die Sonne ist einfach ein heißer glühender Gasball, der irgendwie so vor sich hin brennt. Das tut er glücklicherweise auch noch eine Weile.
Genau, ja. Ein paar Milliarden Jahre noch ungefähr.
Ein paar Milliarden Jahre, dann ist die einfach essig. Bis dahin muss die Menschheit sozusagen einen Weg gefunden haben, wie man auf einem anderen Planeten, also auf ein anderes Sonnensystem umsattelt, weil...
Ja, das weiß das bis dahin noch alles los ist, also... Nee, also wir können mit der Sonne anfangen. Ohne Sonne gibt es kein Sonnensystem. Und je nachdem, was uns interessiert, kann man mit der Sonne auch schon wieder aufhören. Also wenn es nach der Masse geht, dann ist die Sonne eigentlich so gut wie alles, was im Sonnensystem ist. Also fast die gesamte Masse des Sonnensystems ist in der Sonne konzentriert. Alles andere ist so und da fein erliefen. Aber natürlich aus unserer Sicht als...
So 99% oder was?
Genaue Zahlen weiß ich auch nicht. Also Jupiter hat ein Tausendstel der Sonnenmasse. Also bleibt noch so ein bisschen was übrig. Aber das ist jetzt quasi die astronomische Sicht der großen Zahlen. Wenn wir es jetzt aus unserer menschlichen Sicht nehmen, dann ist natürlich die Erde zwar vernachlässigbar gering, aber für uns trotzdem noch groß genug, dass wir sie als relevant ansehen.
Das heißt, die Planeten sind rein von der Masse gesehen eigentlich ein Schiss?
Genau, ja.
Wir sind so ein paar Steinklumpen, die vergessen wurden, eingesammelt zu werden, kann man fast sagen.
Ja, Steinklumpen, das wird ein bisschen zu übertrieben. Aber im Prinzip, wie gesagt, im Vergleich mit der Gesamtmasse sind die Massen der Planeten eigentlich vernachlässigbar klein. Aber trotzdem sind sie natürlich wichtig. Wir haben immerhin acht Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem, die alle auf ihre eigene Art extrem interessant sind.
Wenn diese ganze Masse da drin ist, was ist denn so drin? Ist es wirklich nur Gas, was die ganze Zeit brennt und nichts anderes? Oder geht man davon aus, dass da in der Sonne auch noch irgendein finsterer Kern schlummert, der irgendwie auch feste Materie hat?
Na ja, im Kern der Sonne hat es ein paar Millionen Grad. Da wird nicht mehr viel fest bleiben, egal was da drin war. Die Sonne besteht zu fast 100 Prozent aus Wasserstoff und das Helium. Der Wasserstoff wird im Kern zu Helium fusioniert. Das heißt, je länger die Sonne existiert, desto mehr Helium gibt es im Verhältnis zu Wasserstoff. Aber im Prinzip ist die Beschreibung, die Sonne besteht aus Wasserstoff und Helium, eigentlich ausreichend. Es sind noch ein paar andere Sachen, also das, was die Astronomen Metalle nennen. Für einen Astronomen ist alles, was kein Wasserstoff und kein Helium ist, ein Metall. Und die macht dann noch so einen kleinen Prozentsatz aus von ein paar Prozent, was in der Sonne noch so drin ist, an anderen Kram. Aber im Prinzip ist die Sonne ein großer Ball aus Wasserstoff, der zu Helium fusioniert wird. Nur noch Helium, so, das hängt da wieder von den, das ist wieder ein bisschen komplizierter, hängt es wieder von den genauen Fusionsketten und Fusionsreaktionen ab, die im Inneren ablaufen. Also es wird dann, im späteren Stadium wird das Helium dann auch nochmal fusioniert, das entsteht aus dem Helium, steht wieder was anderes, da gibt es noch Kohlenstoff und Sauerstoff entsteht dann und auch andere schwere Elemente, die alle drin entstehen, aber im Prinzip kommt es dann sowieso noch zu einer mit dieser großen roter Riese, das heißt, die äußeren Schichten schlüsst es dann ab und was dann übrig bleibt in dem Fall ist ein weißer Zwerg, der fast nur noch aus, der dann eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr wirklich fusioniert, sondern eigentlich nur noch Wärmeenergie abstrahlt.
Also roter Riese, weißer Zwerg, das sind so Bezeichnungen für bestimmte Phasen eines Sternenlebens.
Eigentlich kann man schon sprechen von Sternentod. Wenn ein Stern aufhört zu fusionieren, bzw. wenn er nicht aufhört, sondern wenn das Gleichgewicht im Stern sich verändert, ein Stern wird quasi von zwei großen Kräften dominiert. Es gibt einerseits die Gravitationskraft, die im Prinzip die ganze Materie des Sternes zusammenziehen will und dann gibt es den Strahlungsdruck, das ist durch die Strahlung, die erzeugt wird, das Licht, das erzeugt wird, das drückt quasi nach außen. Diese zwei Kräfte halten sich bei einem normalen Stern wie die Sonne, halten sich die beiden Kräfte die Waage. Der Stern wird nicht größer, er wird nicht kleiner, sondern er fusioniert stabil und bleibt stabil. Und irgendwann, gegen Ende des Lebens, der Sonne z.B., wird, wenn der Treibstoff aufgebraucht ist, der Strahlungsdruck schwächer. die Gravitation gewinnt die Überhand, die Gravitationskraft wird stärker, und der Stern wird zusammengedrückt. Wenn er zusammengedrückt wird, dann wird es innen wieder heißer. Aber der Druck steigt, die Temperatur steigt. Wenn es heißer wird, dann können aber neue Kernreaktionen starten. Dann wird es heiß genug, dass eben nicht nur Wasserstoff fusioniert werden kann, sondern auch Helium fusioniert werden kann. Dadurch steigt der Strahlungsdruck wieder, und der ganze WP wird ausgedehnt. Und so geht es dann immer hin und her. Und je nachdem, wie der Stern aufgebaut ist, was die Grundparameter sind, die Grundgröße, kann es dann zum Beispiel in einer Supernova enden, wo das Ding dann quasi explodiert und alles rausschmeißt, oder eben, wie es bei der Sonne sein wird. Die bläht sich dann einfach nur noch auf, da gewinnt dann irgendwann der Strahlungsdruck quasi die Überhand. Die Sonne wird immer größer und immer größer und stößt ihre äußersten Schichten dann ab. Also das geht dann bis über die Erdbahn hinaus. Also die Erde wird dann quasi von der Sonne verschluckt werden. Bis dann irgendwann nur noch bis die ganzen äußersten Schichten abgestoßen sind und nur noch der innerste, dichte Kern übrig bleibt, eben ein weißer Zwerg. Das ist dann ein Ding, so groß wie die Erde ungefähr, was dann auch im Rest des Lebens nicht mehr viel tut. Also der weiße Zwerg ist da und wird dann irgendwann immer kälter, immer dunkler, bis er dann irgendwann ein schwarzer Zwerg wird, der dann, ja, da passiert dann quasi nichts mehr. Also er ist dann ein schwarzer Zwerg und das war's. Und das bleibt auch bis zum Ende des Universums.
Das ist ja einfach nur so ein Klumpenmaterial.
Das ist genau, einfach so ein Stück ausgebrannte Sternenasche quasi.
Kann aber sein, dass es dann irgendwann mal von so einem anderen Sternensystem eingeholt wird.
Ach ja, natürlich kann dann noch irgendwie ein anderer Stern dann wieder mal eingefangen werden, ja, aber das ist sicher, das ist ja unbescheidlich, weil ja doch zwischen den Sternen viel, viel Platz ist.
Ja, klar.
Ja, also das ist so...
Das sind ja eigentlich bedauerliche Aussichten für uns.
Ja, aber wir haben noch ein paar Milliarden Jahre Zeit.
Aber gibt einem doch schon so ein gewisses Gefühl der Endlichkeit, oder? Na gut, lassen wir uns nicht deprimieren. Jetzt haben wir also Planeten und anderes Getier, was sich so um diese Sonne herumtummelt. Ich meine, am Anfang muss ja die Sonne da gewesen sein und dann ist sozusagen die Materie, die die Planeten geformt hat, das ist das, was einfach nicht eingefangen wurde, was nicht von der Erde mit angezogen wurde. Oder ist das da wieder rausgefeuert worden?
Ja, also die Sonne hat sich aus einem großen Urnebel, sagt man, gebildet und nachdem die Sonne entstanden ist, also nachdem die angefangen hat zu strahlen, war sie halt noch von einer Scheibe aus Staub und Gas umgeben. Also es hat, so wie im Prinzip jetzt der Saturn von seinen Ringen umgeben ist, war auch die Sonne von einer großen, sehr großen Staub- und Gas-Scheibe umgeben. Und in dieser Staubscheibe haben sich eben die kleinen Staubteilchen zusammengestoßen, sind quasi aneinander kleben geblieben, sind immer größer geworden, immer größer geworden, bis sie das geworden sind, was wir heute Asteroiden nennen. Also Gesteinsbrocken von ein paar Zentimeter Größe bis ein paar 110 Kilometer Größe. Und die sind natürlich auch wieder miteinander zusammengestoßen. Und so sind dann immer, je größer die geworden sind, desto stärker war die Gravitationskraft, desto mehr andere konnten sie wieder einfangen und irgendwann sind immer auf diese Art und Weise Protoplaneten entstanden. Also noch nicht ganz fertige Planeten, die halt so groß waren wie zum Beispiel wie der Mond, wie die Erde, wie der Mars, solche Objekte ungefähr. Und manche davon, die eben schnell genug, groß genug wurden, die konnten dann auch noch jede Menge Gas einfangen, was da rum lag. Die haben sich dann quasi in eine riesengroße Gasthülle zugelegt. Das sind die geworden, die wir heute als Gaspläten kennen, also Jupiter, Saturn, Uranus, Neptun. Dies waren eben die, die eben schnell genug, groß genug geworden sind. Andere wie die Erde, die sind also kleine, vergleichsweise kleine Gesteinsklumpen geblieben, haben sich dann auch im Laufe der Zeit eine Atmosphäre zugelegt. Natürlich ging es am Anfang noch relativ wild zu, weil da ja wesentlich mehr Protoplaneten waren als wir heute haben. Heute haben wir acht große Planeten im System. Damals waren es mehr und die sind dann auch teilweise zusammengekracht. Also die Proto-Erde ist mit einem anderen Protoplaneten zusammengestoßen. Man nennt den heute Thea. Und damals ist eben aus der Erde ein großes Stück rausgeschlagen worden bei dieser Kollision. Also Thea war so groß wie der Mars. Also da ist die Proto-Erde mit einem maßgroßen, anderen Protoplaneten zusammen gestoßen. Und bei der Kollision ist ein Stück aus der Erde rausgeschlagen worden. Und aus dem ist unser Mond entstanden. Und solche Kollisionen gab es damals noch öfter, bis dann irgendwann eben quasi alles, was irgendwie im Weg rumstand, entweder zusammen gestoßen ist oder rausgeworfen worden ist. Und dann nur noch die acht übrig blieben, die wir heute kennen.
Das heißt auch alle Monde, die jetzt die anderen Planeten umkreisen, sind vermutlich durch solche Kollisionen entstanden?
Das ist schwierig zu sagen. Der Erdmond ist eine Besonderheit, weil der im Vergleich mit der Erde selbst sehr groß ist. Wenn man sich andere anschaut, die Jupiter zum Beispiel hat über 60 Monde, aber im Vergleich zu Jupiter selbst sind das nur winzig kleine Brocken. Die hat er wahrscheinlich einfach eingefangen. Das sind einfach eingefangene Asteroiden. Oder man kann sich auch so vorstellen, dass die genauso entstanden sind wie die Planeten der Sonne. So wie die Sonne von der Scheibe umgeben war, waren auch vielleicht manche Protoplaneten von der Scheibe umgeben, wo sich dann die gleichen Prozesse abgespielt haben und dann auch wieder Monde entstanden sind.
Warum eine Scheibe? Du hast ja gesagt, so wie man das von den Saturn-Ringen erkennt. Also wirklich so quasi in der Mitte, quasi um den Äquator herum und dann eben so eine flache Struktur. Warum tummelt sich das nicht überall?
Man kann das schon beim Saturn recht gut erklären. Die Saturn-Ringe ist extrem flach, wenn man die mit ihrer Ausdehnung vergleicht. Die sind ja hunderttausende Kilometer von der Ausdehnung her. Aber von der Dicke her nur ein paar Kilometer. Also wirklich dünner als ein Blatt Papier, wenn man das so umrechnet. Das kann man mal gut erklären, warum das so ist. Man braucht es sich nur vorstellen, man hätte jetzt mal so Teilchen, so Saturn-Ringe bestehen aus kleinen Gesteins- und Eisbrocken. Wenn man sich jetzt vorsieht, man hätte Teilchen, die jetzt eben nicht in der gleichen Ebene sich befinden wie der Ring, sondern eben dazu geneigt sind. Dann müssen die bei ihrem Umlauf immer diese Ring-Ebene durchqueren. Wenn sie nicht in der Ebene sind, dann müssen sie die Ebene kreuzen. Auf der einen Seite kommen sie von unten nach oben durch. Auf der anderen Seite kommen sie von oben nach unten durch. Und jedes Mal, wenn sie das tun, besteht die Chance, dass sie mit den Teilchen der Ring-Ebene kollidieren. Und jedes Mal, wenn sie zusammenstoßen, verlieren sie ein bisschen Energie. Wenn sie Energie verlieren, dann wird der Orbit flacher. Das heißt, wenn sie das lang genug machen, dann landen die automatisch alle in der gleichen Ebene.
Der Orbit wird deshalb flacher, weil um den Äquator herum am meisten die Kräfte existieren.
Die sammeln sich einfach daran. Wenn du quasi die Teilchen hast, die sich durch die Ebene durchbewegen, wenn du Teilchen hast, die sich durch die Ebene durchbewegen und von dieser Ebene abweichen, dann werden die Kollisionen automatisch wieder zurückgeholt.
Ja gut, aber da muss ja überhaupt erst mal was sein. Was ist, wenn auf der Ring-Ebene noch gar nichts ist, sondern es fliegt nur irgendwo herum, dann können die ja irgendwo miteinander kollidieren. Aber du meinst, in dem Moment, wo sie kollidieren, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie sich am Ende auf das Äquator, das ist der richtige Begriff dafür, also der Erde ist das Äquator.
Ja, das ist auch der Äquator, das hängt dann davon ab, wenn du jetzt quasi eine Bewegung haben willst, die nicht irgendwo vom Äquator abweicht, dann musst du eben die zusätzliche Kraft aufwenden. Also dann die Bewegung wirklich genau um den Äquator, rundherum, das ist die natürliche Bewegung, die sich halt einfach normaler, ganz normal einstunden, wenn das alles passiert.
Das heißt, alles ist irgendwie um die Sonne herumgeflogen, was sich irgendwie noch nie so in der Sonne selbst versammelt hat, stieß zusammen, ist irgendwie ein bisschen verschmolzen oder auch nicht, hatte unterschiedliche Größen. Und man muss sich aber dann diese Ausdehnung dieses Sonnenrings schon so weit vorstellen wie jetzt auch die Ausdehnung unserer Planeten oder haben die sich erst später in diese Abstände hinbewegt?
Die Planeten haben sich schon ein bisschen bewegt, also die sind nicht dort entstanden, wo sie jetzt sind. Man weiß heute, dass sich von den großen Planeten zumindest, also Jupiter, Saturn, Uranus, Neptun, dass die sich nach außen bewegt haben. Also Saturn, Uranus, Neptun haben sich ein bisschen nach außen bewegt. Die waren früher näher in der Sonne dran. Und Jupiter ist ein bisschen nach innen gewandert.
Aber im Wesentlichen waren sie schon da?
Im Wesentlichen waren sie schon da, wo sie jetzt sind.
Okay, also dieser Ring um die Sonne muss man sich im Prinzip fast so groß vorstellen, wie auch heute die Ausdehnung der Planeten ist.
Wir sind also außerhalb, wenn wir jetzt in den Bereich gehen, hinter die Planetenbahnen, also hinter die Bahnen von Neptun, dann ist dieser Ring im Prinzip noch da. Außerhalb der Neptunbahn ist der Kuipergürtel, also ein sehr großer Asteroidengürtel, viel größer als der zwischen den Bahnen von Mars und Jupiter. Und dieser große Asteroidengürtel, der Kuipergürtel, das sind im Prinzip die Dinger, die übrig geblieben sind.
Also das, was nicht verteilt wurde.
Genau, das sind auch die Asteroiden zwischen Mars und Jupiter. Also die Asteroiden sind im Prinzip die übrig gebliebenen Bausteine, aus denen nichts geworden ist.
Kann man aus denen noch was machen?
Na ja, wenn man was machen könnte, dann wäre es schon geschehen.
Na ja, weiß nicht, ich meine, die Zeit ist ja...
Man kann natürlich, wenn man jetzt irgendwie... Ja, aber von selbst wird da jetzt nicht mehr viel passieren. Also wenn, dann müsste man sich selbst noch irgendwie die einsammeln, und dann kann man noch irgendwie was draus bauen, eine Dyson-Sphäre oder so was Science-Fiction-mäßiges. Aber so die Planeten, die entstehen konnten, die sind alle schon entstanden.
Okay. Es sei denn, es kommt mal ein Objekt, so ein großes und unerwartetes, vorbei geschossen, und dann hat er rein und...
Dann, ja, wird natürlich wieder alles durchgemischt, ja.
Dann haben wir hier unter Umständen auch noch ein ganz anderes Problem.
Genau.
Okay, verstehe. Das heißt der Asteroidengürtel, das heißt es gibt zwei...
Eigentlich kommt darauf an, wie man es definiert. Es gibt eigentlich...
Zwei Häufungen.
Häufungen, genau. Es gibt eigentlich fünf Asteroidengürtel große. Also es gibt fünf große Asteroidengruppen. Wenn wir jetzt mal von innen nach außen gehen, dann sind da zuerst die erdnahen Asteroiden. Das sind die Asteroiden, die sich so zwischen der Bahn von Venus und Mars ungefähr befinden. Das sind die Asteroiden, die dann auch... Wenn uns mal einer trifft, dann trifft uns einer von den erdnahen Asteroiden. Dann gibt es die schon angesprochenen Asteroidengürtel, also die nennt man Hauptgürtel-Asteroiden. Das sind die zwischen Mars und Jupiter. Dann gibt es die Trojaner-Asteroiden. Das sind Asteroiden, die sich auf der gleichen Bahn befinden wie Jupiter, nur eben ein bisschen vor und ein bisschen hinter Jupiter. Also da gibt es spezielle Punkte, wo sich die Gravitationskraft von Jupiter und der Sonne genau aufheben. Den nennt man Lagrange-Punkte. Und an den Lagrange-Punkten, also an zwei der fünf Lagrange-Punkte, die Jupiter-Bahnen, haben sich eben Asteroiden angesammelt. Recht viele, also durchaus so viele wie zum Beispiel im Hauptgürtel sich befinden. Und das sind die Trojaner-Asteroiden. Dann zwischen den Bahnen von Jupiter und Neptun gibt es die Zentauren. Das ist im Prinzip das Gegenstück zu den Erdnern-Asteroiden. Also die Erdnern-Asteroiden sind quasi die, die aus dem Hauptgürtel rausgeflogen sind und dann halt wild durch die Planeten, so wie beim Billard, quasi hin und her geschubst werden und diese in den Bereich zwischen den Planeten verteilen. Und die Zentauren sind die Asteroiden, die vom Kuipergürtel weiter draußen rausgeschmissen worden sind und sich dann eben in den Bereich zwischen Jupiter und Neptunbahn verteilen. Das sind die Zentauren. Und dann weiter aushalb kommt eben der große Kuipergürtel, der von zahlenmäßig her vermutlich die größte Anzahl an Asteroiden hält.
Also eine ganze Menge Schrott sozusagen.
Es geht dann noch weiter. Es gibt dann noch die gestreute Scheibe, nennt sich das. Das Ketterdisk ist der Fachausdruck. Das ist quasi der Übergangsbereich zur Ortschen Wolke. Und die ist dann wirklich das alleräußerste Ende. Also die Ortsche Wolke, die geht fast, das äußerste Ende der Ortschen Wolke ist ungefähr hunderttausendmal weiter weg von der Sonne als die Erde. Also das ist fast schon so die Hälfte des Wegs bis zum nächsten Stern ungefähr. Und das ist eben der Bereich, wo der ganze Kram der Plnetenentstehung rausgeschmissen worden ist. Die ganzen Asteroiden, die bei der Planetentstehung durch die Gravitationskräfte der Planeten rausgeworfen sind, sich eben angesammelt hat und die Sonne in so einer kugelförmigen Schale im Prinzip umgibt, wo auch die meisten Kometen herkommen.
Ah ja, okay, also das ist dann wirklich der Schrottplatz sozusagen.
Genau, ja. Also da gibt es noch viel, viel mehr, so ein paar wirklich Milliarden.
Okay, jetzt denke ich, ist das ganz hilfreich, dass wir jetzt vielleicht wirklich nochmal so den Marsch von innen nach außen nochmal konkret machen, weil wir die ganze Zeit diese Bezugspunkte haben, was wo ist. Also wir haben die Sonne. Was ist dann das erste nennenswerte Objekt ab der Sonne?
Das würde mehr Kurs sein, denke ich.
Okay, Planet, haben wir schon gehört, zieht seine Kreise, hat enorm viel Wirkung von der Sonne, das ist bestimmt scheiße heiß.
Da ist es, ja, allerdings. Der ist auch so, dass es, je nachdem, ob man jetzt auf der sonnenzugewandten Seite oder der sonnenabgewandten Seite ist, auf der abgewandten Seite von der Sonne ist es wahnsinnig kalt, weil ja die Atmosphäre, der weggepustert worden ist quasi, also Merkur hat keine Atmosphäre, es ist einfach nur ein nacktes Stück Fels. Und je nachdem, es ist entweder wahnsinnig heiß oder wahnsinnig kalt dort.
Das heißt, wenn man so gerade dazwischen irgendwo ist, dann gibt es vielleicht auch einen wohlklimatisierten Bereich?
Ja, auch nicht wirklich. Merkur ist generell ziemlich ungebütlich, weil es gibt auch keine Atmosphäre und nichts dort.
Kann man ihn überhaupt sehen?
Merkur kann man sehen, ja. Es ist kürzlich Planeten, die man mit freien Augen sehen kann. Ist aber von denen, die man mit freien Augen sehen kann, am schwächsten sichtbar. Man muss auch wirklich genau wissen, wo man hinguckt, denn Merkur ist nahe bei der Sonne. Das heißt, man kann ihn nur sehen kurz nachdem die Sonne untergegangen ist oder kurz bevor die Sonne aufgeht, also früh am Abend oder früh am Morgen. Und wenn man genau weiß, wo man hinguckt, dann kann man ihn durchaus auch sehen. Dann? Nach Merkur kommt die Venus. Dazwischen gibt es wieder ein paar verstreute Asteroiden, die Sun-Gracers, also Asteroiden, die nahe an die Sonne rankommen oder Kometen, die nahe an die Sonne rankommen. Aber das ist eher zum Vergleich mit den restlichen Gruppen vernachlässigbar. Also das nächste relevante Ding wäre dann wirklich die Venus im Planet, der eher alles sehr ähnlich ist, also fast genauso groß ist wie die Erde, aber halt von der Physik her, von den Bedingungen her doch ganz anders ist, weil eben Venus, im Gegensatz zu Merkur, der überhaupt keine Atmosphäre hat, hat Venus eine wahnsinnig dichte Atmosphäre, also wirklich extrem dicht. Die haben einen mega Treibhaus-Effekt dort, also die haben da die Oberflächentemperatur so ein paar Hundert Grad, weil eben wirklich die so einen wahnsinnigen starken, starke Wolkendecke so einen starken Treibhaus-Effekt haben. Die haben Schwefel-Wolken, die sie da rumtreiben, also es ist auch ein wirklich ungemütlicher Platz.
Lass uns gleich mal so zu den Eigenschaften der Planeten nochmal separat kommen, dass wir überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen so die Verortung haben. Also wir haben Merkur, dann noch ein bisschen Asteroidenkram, Venus.
Danach kommt Erde und Mond.
Erde und Mond?
Aber wie gesagt, es ist auch immer mit den Erden und Asteroiden dazwischen. Die sind so zwischen Venus und Mars, sind die Erden und Asteroiden. Dann kommt Erde und Mond, danach ist der Mars, mit seinen zwei Monden, die jetzt auch nicht sonderlich interessant sind. Natürlich sind auch die Mars-Monde interessant, aber sie sind insofern interessant, als die die einzigen neben unserem Mond, die einzigen anderen Monde sind, die einer von den inneren Himmelskörpern hat. Normalerweise haben nur die großen Gasriesen, die später kommen, haben alle jede Menge Monde, aber im inneren System, Merko hat keinen Mond, Venus hat keinen Mond, die Erde hat ihren einen Mond und Mars hat eben zwei kleine, winzige Monde. Nach dem Mars kommt der große Asteroidenglück.
Da gab es vor einiger Zeit einen großartigen Comic von XKCD, wo er die Gravitation der einzelnen Planeten und ihrer Monde in einer anschaulichen Grafik eine durchgehende Linie gezogen hat, wo man schnell sehen konnte, mit wie viel Kraft man aufbringen muss, um sich von dem jeweiligen Objekt wegzubewegen. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, waren das die Marsmonde, wo man sich dann problemlos mit dem Fahrrad und einer kleinen Rampe wegschießen kann.
Die Marsmonde sind vermutlich nur eingefangene Asteroiden, kleine Felsbrocken, wo man vermutlich auch mit einem Fahrrad oder Skateboard ins All könnte, wenn man wollte. Nach Mars kommt dann der Hauptgürtel der Asteroiden, dort wo die großen Asteroiden sind. Da drin ist auch ein Zwergplanet der seit 2006, eine neue Klasse von Objekten, die Zwergplaneten. Das ist Ceres, der größte Asteroid im Hauptgürtel und eben auch ein Zwergplanet.
Was macht ihr denn dann zum Zwergplaneten?
Ach Gott, diese ganze Planetendefinitionsgeschichte, da gab es ja Rietenschreitereien und Diskussionen im Jahr 2006.
Wegen Pluto und so.
Ja, weil es wirklich schwierig ist, genau zu definieren, was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Planeten und einem Asteroiden. Nach oben hin kann man es leicht erklären. Der Unterschied zwischen Stern und Planet ist leicht. Ein Stern erzeugt eben dauerhaft selbst die Energie, ein Planet nicht. Ein Planet macht keine Kernfusionen oder sowas. Aber nach unten hin ist es wirklich schwierig. Es gibt keine natürliche Grenze, wie es nach oben hin mit der Fusion gibt. Das gibt es nach unten hin nicht. Da werden die Dinge einfach wirklich immer kleiner, kontinuierlich kleiner. Und man könnte jetzt einfach wildkürlich irgendwo sagen, ok, alles, was größer als das ist, ist ein Planet, alles, was kleiner als das ist, ist ein Asteroid. Aber das macht physikalisch nicht wirklich Sinn. Man hat sich eben damals für diese Definition entschieden, dass man gesagt hätte, das muss ein Planet zumindest so schwer sein, dass seine eigene Gravitation in eine annähernd runde Form bringt, dass er unter seiner eigenen Gravitationskraft zu einer runden Form zusammenfindet. Da muss er groß genug sein, damit das funktioniert. Und er muss seine Umgebung freigeräumt haben. Das war das, was ich vorhin gemeint habe bei der Planetentstehung, dass die Objekte in ihrer Umgebung alles aufgesammelt haben. Wenn sie groß genug geworden sind, haben die ganzen anderen Asteroiden, die herumgespürt sind, alle quasi angezogen oder rausgeschmissen. Je nachdem, aber sie haben in ihrer um näheren Umgebung aufgeräumt. Und manche Objekte sind auch groß geworden, ebenso wie Pluto, Ceres, die anderen Zwergplaneten Eris, die sind so ein paar hundert oder tausend Kilometer groß geworden, aber haben es eben nicht geschafft, schnell genug groß genug zu werden, um eben den ganzen anderen Schrott in ihrer Umgebung rauszuschmeißen. Man hat eben gesagt, was jetzt groß genug ist, um rund zu sein, und was alles andere in seiner Umgebung rausgeschmissen hat, ist ein Planet. Und was zwar groß genug ist, um rund zu sein, aber nichts rausgeschmissen hat, ist ein Asteroid. Es ist ein Zwergplanet. Und im Prinzip kann man sagen, Zwergplanet ist nur ein anderes Wort für große Asteroid. Aber wir haben jetzt diese Klassifikation, dass es neben Planeten auch Zwergplaneten gibt. Und so ist das halt.
Die Asteroiden sind halt nicht rund. Die sind halt irgendwie, so wie man das von Asteroids im Spiel kennt, irgendwie komisch aus.
Aber das ist halt auch der einzige Unterschied, der Unterschied zwischen Zwergplaneten und Asteroiden ist halt wirklich nur die Form. Und die ist wieder direkt zurückzugehen auf die Masse. Zwergplaneten sind einfach größer, es ist einfach schwerer als ein Asteroid. Aber von der Bahn her, von der Dynamik her, gibt es eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied zwischen den Objekten.
Okay, also im Asteroidengürtel gibt es Ceres. Und der ist recht groß. Der ist ja auch größer als Pluto?
Nee, Ceres ist kleiner als Pluto.
Hat man den auch schon immer irgendwie gesehen?
Ceres hat man 1801 entdeckt. Das ist auch eine nette Geschichte. Damals hat man auch nach neuen Planeten gesucht. Also man hat nicht nur mit Neptune einen neuen Planeten gefunden, sondern eben auch früher schon gesucht danach, weil es nämlich damals die sogenannte Tizius-Bodhische Reihe gab. Das heißt, man hat früher die Planeten gekannt, die auch schon die Antiken, die Menschen in der Antike kannten, Merkur, Venus, Erde, Mars, Jupiter und Saturn. Die kannte man quasi schon immer. Und dann hat Herrschl 1700 irgendwas, 56, ich weiß es nicht genau, hat den Planeten Uranus entdeckt. Das war der erste Planet, der Neuzeit gefunden wurde. Und dann gab es eben ein paar Wissenschaftler, eben Tizius und Bode, die gemeint haben, sie hätten eine Gesetzmäßigkeit bei den Abständen entdeckt. Also jeder Planet hat einen gewissen Abstand von der Sonne und die haben gemeint, dass es eine Gesetzmäßigkeit gibt. Ja, also Merkur ist 0,4 astronomische Einheiten von der Sonne weg, Venus ist 0,7 astronomische Einheiten weg, die Ades ist eine astronomische Einheit weg und so weiter. Und die haben gemeint, es gibt ein simples Gesetz, das beschreibt, wie weit ein Planet weg ist. Also der erste Planet muss so und so weit weg sein, der zweite Planet muss so und so weit weg sein und so weiter. Und man hat eben zufällig herausgefunden, dass es eben wirklich für die Zahlen von 1 bis 5 genau übereingestimmt hat oder fast genau übereingestimmt hat. Und dann habe ich eben einen neuen Planeten entdeckt, den Uranus, und der hat auch noch genau reingepasst in dieses Schema. Und man war eigentlich damals wirklich überzeugt, dass diese Titsius-Buddhische Reihe die Abstände im Sonnensystem wirklich genau beschreibt. Der einzige Schönezfehler war, dass es eben an einer Position eine Lücke gegeben hat. Also man laut dieser Reihe hätte auch zwischen Mars und Jupiter noch ein Planet sein sollen. Und weil man wirklich überzeugt davon war, dass diese Reihe stimmt, weil die eben auch durch Uranus so schön bestätigt worden ist, haben sich eben alle Astronomen auf die Suche gemacht, diesen unbekannten Planeten zwischen Mars und Jupiter zu finden. Und hat eben 1801 wirklich genau in dem Bereich, wo dieser sein sollte nach der Titsius-Buddhischen Reihe, eben ein Objekt entdeckt. Das war Ceres. Man war wirklich glücklich. Man hat auch Ceres damals eben auch als Planeten bezeichnet. Also es war wirklich so wie die anderen, war auch Ceres ein Planet. Bis dann ein paar Jahre später dort in der Gegend noch mehr Planeten gefunden wurden. Also genau da, wo Ceres ist, aber auch noch andere entdeckt, Palas, Juno und Vesta und dann noch ein paar mehr. Also es war nur möglich, dass dann 1820 rum in der Zeit gab es dann wirklich schon so 20, 30 Planeten, die alle zwischen Mars und Jupiter waren. Und das war eigentlich so nicht das, was man wollte. Man wollte da einen Planeten haben, der in diese Titsius-Buddhische Reihe reinpasst, wo man nicht jetzt irgendwie einen ganzen Haufen von Planeten, die alle auf der gleichen Bahn mehr oder weniger sind. Man hat dann auch bald festgestellt, dass diese Dinger eben sehr, sehr klein sind. Und dann auch wirklich ist dazu übergegangen, die jetzt nicht Planet zu nennen, sondern eben Asteroiden.
Weil die auch nicht rund waren.
Das hat man damals noch nicht gewusst. Also so genau konnte man das nicht beobachten.
Ja, waren es aber nicht.
Genau. Das hat dann eben auch wieder so ein bisschen, vielleicht auch ein bisschen so Neid oder interne Streitereien dabei gewesen, weil das Wort Asteroid hat Herstel vorgeschlagen, der damals immer den Uranus entdeckt hat, also der wirklich der erste war, der einen neuen Planeten entdeckt hatte und der wollte wahrscheinlich nicht, dass irgendwie andere auch noch Planeten entdeckt haben. Dann hat er gemeint, nenne die Dinge mal Asteroid und nicht Planet. Aber wie auch immer, das hat sich dann so eingebürgert, dass eben diese Asteroiden genannt, dass die Asteroide genannt worden sind. Man hat dann im Laufe der Zeit immer mehr und mehr gefunden, bis man eben dann gesehen hat, okay, da zwischen Mars und Jupiter, da ist kein Planet, sondern ein großer Haufen von kleinen Objekten, die Asteroide genannt werden. Und Ceres war eben dann der, obwohl er eine Zeit lang als Planet bezeichnet worden ist, war Ceres eben der erste Asteroid, den man entdeckt hat.
Aber Asteroid ist ja eigentlich auch ein Name, der könnte ja nun falscher kaum sein, ne? Eigentlich heißt das ja so Sternchen, oder?
Genau, ja.
Aber ich meine, da ist ja nun von Kernfusionen nicht zu sehen irgendwie auf so einem kleinen Stück Fels.
Ja, also so ein kleiner Lichtpunkt, das kleine Sternchen im Himmel oder sowas, also dass die kleine Zeichnung, ich weiß nicht genau, wie Herr Schloss dieses Wort gekommen ist, warum man es so zu nennen wollte.
Hat auf jeden Fall verfangen.
Es ist oft so, ja, wenn halt die Traditionen mal was, was sich eingebürgert hat, dann ist schwer zu ändern.
Okay, also weiter der Marsch nach draußen. Also wir waren bei Mars, dann kam jetzt dieser Asteroidengürtel und da tummelt sich so einiges, vor allem der Ceres, der so ein bisschen rund ist und noch so einige andere, die es nicht geschafft haben, so richtig rund zu sein, sind aber keine richtigen Planeten, sondern fast alles Asteroiden, bis auf den Ceres, der als Zwergplanet qualifiziert wird.
Danach kommt Jupiter mit den Jupiter-Trojanern.
Vor allem kommt da erstmal eine ganze Weile nichts, oder? Also der Abstand ist ja dann schon...
Na ja, es kommt darauf an, dass man die Abstände natürlich sind groß, aber verglichen mit den anderen Abständen, also zwischen Asteroidengürteln und Jupiter, da ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel Lücke dabei. Also der Asteroidengürtel hört bei ungefähr so vier astronomischen Einheiten auf und bei fünf astronomischen Einheiten kommt schon Jupiter und dazwischen sind auch ein paar Asteroiden, also da ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig große Lücken. Ja, Jupiter, der größte Planet, mit ganz einem Schwarm von Monden, ich weiß nicht, wie viele man jetzt schon kennt, da gibt es auch immer neue, aber auf irgendwie so um über 60 wieder schon haben, die man kennt, und sind ein Trojaner Asteroiden. Dann, nächste große Planet, zweitgrößte Planet im Sonnensystem ist Saturn, den jede Menge Ringe und auch einen ganzen Schwung Monde mit dabei. Dann weiter außen Uranus und Neptun, ebenfalls alle mit Monden und Ringen.
Die haben auch Ringe?
Jupiter, Saturn, Uranus, Neptun haben alle Ringe, ja.
Auch wenn man die nicht so sieht?
Also den Saturnring kann man mit einem kleinen Teleskop sehen, aber die Jupiter und die Ringe von Jupiter, Uranus und Neptun, die sind schwerer zu sehen, aber sind alle da, ja. Es könnte sogar sein, dass Mars Ringe hat, aber das ist...
Unklar noch.
Vermutlich eher nicht, aber es ist die Möglichkeit bestünde, dass er noch welche hat. Aber aus anderen Gründen gibt es die beiden Monde, die dem Mars umkreisen und wenn da jetzt so kleine Meteoriten auf den Mond einschlagen, dann fällt der Staub raus und weil die so winzig sind, können die den Staubkurs nicht festhalten, das heißt, er fliegt ins Weltall und dieser Staub könnte sich eben auf so einem Ring ansammeln um Mars herum, den man theoretisch nachweisen könnte, aber bis jetzt hat man es noch nicht geschafft. Also man weiß nicht, ob es die wirklich gibt oder nicht. Aber wie gesagt, Uranus und Neptun haben auf jeden Fall Ringe und jede Menge Monde und das war es dann im Prinzip bei Neptun, was die Planeten angeht. Dahinter kommt dann noch Pluto, Zwergplanet, mit seinem großen Mond Charon und dann die große Kuipergürtel der Asteroiden. Und das ist quasi soweit, haben wir bis jetzt gesehen, also die Kuipergürtel-Asteroiden, die ersten hat man 1992 in den ersten Asteroiden im Kuipergürtel entdeckt. Mittlerweile haben wir schon einige hundert gefunden, obwohl es natürlich viel, viel mehr gibt. Wir haben sogar schon ein Objekt entdeckt, das heißt Sedna, auch ein relativ vergleichbar großer Asteroid, der wirklich verdammt weit von der Sonne weggeht, wo man auch schon glaubt, dass der vielleicht so ein Übergangsobjekt ist in den allerinnersten Bereichen der Ortschen Wolke, aber wie gesagt weiter raus, also wirklich in den äußersten Bereichen, die Ortsche Wolke, die wirkliche Ortsche Wolke, da haben wir, wir wissen zwar, dass es sie geben muss, aber ein konkretes Objekt beobachtet haben wir doch nicht davon, weil die einfach so wahnsinnig weit weg sind und so klein sind, dass die kaum zu sehen sind. Was wir noch vergessen haben bei den Objekten sind die Kometen, die haben eigentlich nicht so wirklich einen Platz im Sonnensystem, weil die wirklich die meisten halt einfach so kurze Besucher sind. Also die kommen und dann gehen sie und dann sind sie weg. Also die kommen, wie gesagt, aus der Ortschen Wolke durch, zum Beispiel wenn ein anderer Stern mal nahe an der Sonne vorbeikommt, können die ein bisschen gestört werden, gravitativ, dann ändert sich die Bahn ein bisschen, dann kommt er ins innere Sonnensystem rein, fängt an zu leuchten, dreht einmal eine Runde um die Sonne und fliegt wieder raus und lässt sich für die nächsten paar, 10, 100.000 Jahre nicht mehr blicken. Diese Kometen sind wichtige, relevante Bestandteile des Sonnensystems, aber man kann sie nicht so wirklich in Platz zu raten.
Also jetzt vielleicht nochmal den Überblick fertig machen. Also wir haben in der Mitte die Sonne, da ist fast die ganze Materie drin, dann haben wir eine ganze Reihe von Planeten, das geht dann eben bis zum Neptune. Und dann gibt es noch Asteroiden, nicht wahr? Ja, eben mit dem Pluto als Zwergplaneten. Dann gibt es auch diverse andere Zwergplaneten, die da auch noch sind, die teilweise noch größer sind. Ich hab gerade gesehen, der letzte heißt Eris.
Eris ist der größte Zwergplanet. Das ist auch der Planet, der diese ganze Debatte eigentlich erst angestoßen hat. Ach wirklich? Ja, es war ja damals...
Wies er dann schon Eris oder haben sie ihn deswegen so genannt?
Sie haben ihn deswegen so genannt, ja.
Weil er der Planet des Streits ist?
Genau, der Mond von Eris heißt Dysnomia, wo ich jetzt auch nicht ganz sicher bin, aber es dürfte auch irgendwie so eine Streit-Mythologie sein, irgendwie so eine Art... passt immer auch dazu. Also die ursprünglich waren ja die Namen... hießen die ja... man hat hier lange nicht... man hat sich lange nicht von offiziellen Namen entschieden, aber der inoffizielle Name war lange Zeit von Eris, hieß Xena nach der Fantasy-Serie im Fernsehen. Und der Mond hieß Gabrielle nach der Freundin von Xena in der Fantasy-Serie. Da dürften die Beobachter, keine Ahnung, Fans von dieser Fantasy-Serie gewesen sein. Aber das war das Ding, man hat ja quasi lange Zeit, schon lange diskutiert, ob Pluto so ein Planet ist oder nicht. Man hat Pluto 1930, glaube ich, in einem Drehraum jemand entdeckt und hat nie so wirklich reingepasst. Wir haben innen im Sonnensystem die kleinen Planeten, die felsigen Planeten mit fester Oberfläche, Merkuvinus, Erde, Mars und weiter außen die großen Planeten. Und dann ist da wieder so ein winziger kleines Ding ins Pluto da draußen, was eigentlich gar nicht reinpasst. Man hat lange auch die Bahn von Pluto, die ist ein bisschen anders, also sie ist viel stärker geneigt als die anderen Planetenbahnen. Dann hat er auch noch so einen großen Mond. Also der Pluto hat irgendwie nie so richtig reingepasst in das Schema. Aber man hat ihm damals in der Gegend nichts anderes gekannt. Also es war allen klar, dass Pluto halt einfach als Planet gezählt worden ist, weil er einfach auch da draußen war. Und wenn er auch nicht größer war als Merkur, war er doch noch groß genug, er war größer als das Mond. Also man hat ihn einfach als Planet mitgezogen. Und erst 1992 hat man dann herausgefunden, dass es da draußen noch sehr viel mehr Asteroiden gibt, dass da eben ein ganzer Gürtel von Asteroiden ist. Und dass Pluto nicht irgendwie alleine da rum sitzt, sondern wirklich im mittendrinnen Asteroiden-Gürtel, mittendrinnen in einer Gruppe von Asteroiden, die sich Plutoiden nennt. Das sind wirklich alles Objekte, das sind wirklich alle, die sind wirklich von der Bahndynamik hier alle mehr oder weniger identisch mit Pluto. Pluto ist halt nur zufällig einfach der größte von denen. Und man hat eben damals schon, haben viele Astronomen gemeint, okay, man sollte jetzt eigentlich Pluto nicht mehr als Planet bezeichnen. Weil er mag zwar groß sein, das größte Objekt, das man da draußen erkennt, aber ansonsten unterscheidet er sich doch nicht von den Asteroiden. Aber die internationale Astronomische Union, die IAU, hat eben immer gesagt, nee, es ist zwar alles richtig, dass das von der Astronomie her nicht wirklich als Planet durchgeht, aber aus historischen Gründen bleibt das jetzt im Planet. Da wollte man jetzt nicht irgendwie anfangen, das alles auseinanderzubringen. Dann hat man aber immer mehr große Asteroiden entdeckt. Es hat angefangen, das war halt irgendwie Quao-A, hieß der einer, ich weiß den Namen jetzt nicht auswendig.
Marke, Marke.
Den zum Beispiel, ja, oder Xion, wie auch immer. Man hat eben jede Menge Asteroiden entdeckt, die wirklich groß waren, also alles ein paar Hundert Kilometer groß. Und hat sich dann schon den Gedanken gemacht, okay, jetzt gibt es da im Kuipergürtel jede Menge große Objekte, die alle Asteroiden sind, und dann gibt es noch ein größeres Objekt, das halt ein Planet ist. Und dann hat eben wirklich Mike Brown ein Objekt entdeckt, das damals noch als Arbeitstitel inoffizieller Name Xena genannt worden ist. Und das war wirklich größer als Pluto. Man hat jetzt fast die absurde Situation gehabt, dass man einen Asteroid gehabt hat, der größer ist als Pluto, aber eben als Asteroid bezeichnet werden muss. Und einen Planeten, der kleiner als der Asteroid ist, der aber halt einfach planetennahm werden muss. Also es war klar, dass man da irgendwas machen muss. Und dann haben die Leute angefangen zu diskutieren. Es gab eben Kommissionen eingerichtet, die haben mir mal legt, was denkt man jetzt aus? Dann war diese 2006 die große Versammlung, IAU-Generalversammlung in Prag war das. Und diese Kommission hat da eben einen Vorschlag veröffentlicht, der nicht wirklich doch gedacht war. Also die erste Version von dem Vorschlag, da hat eben die Sache gefehlt mit dem, was ich von Ihnen gemeint habe, dass Sie Ihre Bahn freiräumen müssen. Da ging es wirklich nur nach, wenn es groß genug ist, im Grund zu sein, ist es ein Planet. Das war damals die Definition. Und das haben die auch PR-technisch ganz mies umgesetzt. Also die Kommission hat quasi diese Definition schon veröffentlicht, an den Medien gemacht, bevor die noch darüber abgestimmt haben, die Astronomen, und haben gesagt, nach dieser Definition, da wäre eben nicht nur Pluton-Planet geblieben, es wäre auch der Mond von Pluto und Karin ein Planet gewesen, Ceres wäre ein Planet gewesen, eben dieser neue Eris. Es hätte dann eben, ich glaube, wäre noch einer dabei gewesen, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, es hätte dann das Sonnensystem eben zwölf Planeten gehabt statt den neun. Natürlich hat jeder große Zeitung aufgemacht, das Sonnensystem hat jetzt zwölf Planeten, die Schlagzeile überall, aber obwohl natürlich die Astronomen noch nicht abgestimmt haben über die Regel. Und die Astronomen haben den Vorschlag abgelehnt, weil er eben wirklich dumm war. Mit der Regel hätten wir dann nach den nächsten zehn Jahren noch offenbar Asteroine draußen entdeckt, die alle groß genug sind, um rund zu sein. Dann hätten wir irgendwie 100, 200 Planeten gehabt im Sonnensystem. Und dann wären wirklich vom kleinsten Felsbrocken bis zum großen Gasriesen alles Planet gewesen. Also es hätte physikalisch, astronomisch überhaupt keinen Sinn gemacht, dieser Vorschlag.
Du warst aber nicht dabei, oder?
Ich war nicht dabei, nee.
Welche Astronomen wurden denn da geladen?
Das sind im Prinzip alle Astronomen, die Mitglied der Internationalen Astronomischen Union sind. Zu diesen Konferenzen kann im Prinzip jeder hinfahren. Das sind ganz normale wissenschaftliche Konferenzen, die alle drei Jahre stattfinden, glaube ich. Ja, alle drei Jahre finden die statt. Eine ganz normale wissenschaftliche Konferenz, wo es aber immer auch extra Sitzungen gibt, wo die Mitglieder der Astronomischen Union sich zusammensetzen und sich zu solchen Sachen zum Beispiel beraten. Und ich war damals nicht dabei, aber ich kenne viele meiner Kollegen waren dabei. Und wie gesagt, die Kommission hat sich dann eben schnell irgendwie so ein bisschen hingepfuscht, einen neuen Vorschlag ausgedacht. Eben der mit dem Planet muss nicht nur rund sein, sondern muss auch seine Bahn freigeräumt haben. Damit wäre dann eben Pluto rausgefallen als Planet.
Das heißt, auf der Bahn, auf der sich Pluto bewegt, sind einfach noch andere Asteroiden?
Das sind jede Menge Asteroiden. Pluto gehört zur Gruppe der Plutoiden, das ist eine eigene Asteroidengruppe, die alle die gleiche Bahn sich teilen.
Also Iris ist sozusagen auf demselben...
Nee, Iris ist nicht, Iris ist mit da draußen. Aber auch alle mitten im Kuipergürtel, also da ist nichts freigeräumt. Also nach der Klassifikation wäre eben Pluto kein Planet mehr gewesen, was im Prinzip okay ist. Also ich hätte jetzt wunderbar damit leben können, wenn Pluto einfach ein großer Asteroid ist. Deswegen wird Pluto nicht weniger interessant oder sonst irgendwas. Also es ist das gleiche Objekt und genauso interessant wie vorher und rein astronomisch, physikalisch macht es aus meiner Sicht viel mehr Sinn, Pluto einfach als großen Asteroid zu bezeichnen. Aber das wollten halt viele nicht, auch aus politischen Gründen, oder ich weiß nicht, ich gebe jetzt hier nur Gerüchte weiter, dass halt vor allem die Amerikaner wollten halt nicht, dass Pluto jetzt degradiert wird, weil Pluto der einzige Planet ist, der von einem Amerikaner entdeckt worden ist. Uranus wurde von einem Briten entdeckt, also einem Deutschen, der in England gearbeitet hat. Neptune wurde von einem Franzosen und einem Deutschen entdeckt.
Und jetzt kommen diese ganzen Astronomen, die wollen uns unseren Planeten wegnehmen.
Es gibt auch in dem Staat, wo der Entdecker von Pluto gearbeitet hat, in Amerika, wo er gewohnt hat, Idaho ist der eine und Arizona der andere, da haben die wirklich Gesetze erlassen, dass in unserem Staat ist Pluto ein Planet. Da gab es halt wieder Streitereien. Deswegen wollen wir, damit Pluto auf der Öffentlichkeit als Planet bleibt.
Deswegen also Zwergplanet. Iris hat mal wieder den ganzen Streit ausgelöst.
Das ist ja ein schönes Bild. Meiner Sicht macht diese Klasse der Zwergplaneten nicht wahnsinnig viel Sinn, weil im Prinzip Zwergplanet ist einfach nur ein Name für große Asteroide.
Ja gut, aber ist das nicht schon eine interessante Eigenschaft, wenn er so viel Masse hat, dass er irgendwie rund ist?
Natürlich ist es eine interessante Eigenschaft, ja, das ist klar.
Also ich finde es schon wert, dass man das irgendwie unterscheidet. So jetzt als Laie?
Ich lehne es jetzt nicht komplett ab, ja. Ich könnte genauso gut ohne leben. Ich bin sowieso der Meinung, dass da vermutlich noch nicht das letzte Wort gesprochen ist. Dass da noch irgendwann jetzt mal, wenn sich die Astronomen ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht haben, wenn die auch mehr Objekte da draußen gefunden haben, dass dann noch mal irgendwie neu geschaut wird, wie das gemacht wird. Ich bin sowieso auch der Meinung, dass es nicht viel Sinn macht, hier so exakte Klassen zu definieren, also das ist ein Planet, das ist ein Asteroid. Man sollte das eben vielleicht so machen wie der Biologie.
Okay, aber es ist ein Denkmodell.
Sinnvoller wäre es, wenn man es so wie in der Biologie macht, wo halt einfach sagt, wo halt die Tiere ja auch, gibt es irgendwie, gibt es den Stamm und gibt es die Gruppe und die Untergruppe und so weiter, wo halt einfach, wenn du jetzt diese biologische Klassifikation hast, hast du einfach eine Reihe von Eigenschaften, die das Tier oder Lebewesen hat. Genauso könnte man es auch bei den Planeten machen, dass man einfach, jedes Himmelsobjekt hat einfach eine Reihe von Eigenschaften, die halt entsprechend klassifiziert werden. Aber wie gesagt, da werden sich die Astronomen sicher noch lange Gedanken machen, darüber wie das abläuft.
Okay, gibt eine Menge zu definieren. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, jetzt sind wir ja schon relativ weit draußen. Eris ist einfach schon verdammt weit weg.
Genau, ja.
Und dann kommt diese Ortsche Wolke, die man so jetzt noch nicht gesehen hat, aber die man einfach vermutet oder sich errechnet hat?
Man weiß zum Beispiel, dass es von den Kometenbahnen her, wir wissen es gibt kurzperiodische Kometen und langperiodische Kometen. Also Kometen, die kurzperiodischen, wie der Komet Halley zum Beispiel, der kommt alle 76 Jahre einmal rundherum. Das heißt, das sind eben Objekte, die aus dem Kuipergürtel, aus dem äußeren Bereich vom Kuipergürtel kommen und dann immer wieder mal um die Sonne rumkommen. Und dann gibt es andere Kometen, das sind eben die Objekte, die man, wenn man im Fernsehen wieder liest, es kommt wieder ein großer Komet, wie hier Gotake zum Beispiel, was es damals gab, wie die alle heißen. Das sind wirklich die, die kommen einmal und dann gehen sie und dann kommen sie im Prinzip nie wieder. Irgendwann kommen sie vielleicht schon noch mal, aber das ist halt in 10.000 Jahren oder 100.000 Jahren. Und irgendwo müssen diese Dinger ja herkommen. Wenn die jetzt so weit weg sind, dann müssen die auch irgendwo herkommen. Die machen ja nicht plötzlich ploppers um nichts, sondern sind da. Die müssen irgendwo herkommen. Und das ist eben dieses Reservoir dieser langperiodischen Kometen. Das ist die Ortsche Wolke. Das ist ein Bereich ganz weit weg von der Sonne, wo eben unmögliche Kometen sind, die ab und zu mal reinkommen. Und man kann eben auch theoretisch begründen, warum dieses Reservoir da sein muss, weil ja bei der Planetenentstehung viele dieser Planetenbausteine rausgeworfen sind. Das sind nicht alle ganz weit rausgeschmissen, das sind nicht alle irgendwie in den interstellaren Raum rausgeschmissen worden, sondern manche sind eben einfach weit weggeschmissen worden, aber dann wieder halt so doch noch an die Sonne gebunden ein bisschen. Und dieses rausgeschmissene Material, das, was im Übblim ist, das muss sich eben irgendwo angesammelt haben, und das ist eben genau die Ortsche Wolke.
Aber die, ich meine diese Kometen, das ist ja jetzt nicht so wie bei diesen Spacenweathers-artigen Computerspielen, so Phoenix oder so, dass die dann immer so oben rumschwören und dann so blblblbl, irgendwann mal entscheiden, loszufliegen. Sondern diese Kometen sind ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit in Bewegung. Wenn du jetzt sagst Reservoir, das klingt ja so ein bisschen, als ob da jederzeit neue Kometen nachgeschickt werden können.
Ja, im Prinzip ist es so. Normalerweise sind diese Dinge in der Ortsche Wolke, die kreisen halt da weit rum und kommen der Sonne nicht nahe. Sie ziehen ihre Bahnen und stellen sich weiter. Aber natürlich...
Aber sie ziehen schon ihre Bahnen auch um die Sonne?
Um die Sonne, aber einfach extrem weit weg, ja. Aber natürlich ist das ganze Ding nicht statisch. Es ändert sich. Es kann zum Beispiel sein, dass nahe Sterne, die Sonne bewegt sich ja auch durch die Galaxie, und da kommt sie mal näher an den anderen Stern vorbei oder mal weniger weiter weg. Dann können so leichte kreative Einflüsse von anderen Sternen kommen. Wenn sie nahe an den anderen Sternen vorbeigeht, dann wird diese Kometen in der Ortsschon-Wolke-Beinung ein bisschen durchgeschüttelt. Die haben andere Bedingungen. Dadurch können sie die Bahn verändern. Oder es kann zum Beispiel sein, dass es auch dort draußen Planeten gibt. Ich habe erzählt, es gab Protoplaneten, mehr Protoplaneten als wir jetzt haben. Die sind entweder zerstört worden oder kollidiert oder immer auch rausgeworfen. Es kann auch gut sein, dass da draußen noch ein paar größere Planeten rumspüren. Die kann sein, ist wahrscheinlich auch gut möglich, nur wir werden keine Möglichkeit haben, die in naher Zukunft zu entdecken, weil die einfach so weit weg sind. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass da Planeten ganz weit draußen rumschwirren, die dann auch, je nachdem, wie die ihre Bahn sich ändern, die Kometen beeinflussen können, normal ein bisschen anstupsen, der dann wieder ins innere Sonnensystem reinkommt. Oder einfach zwei Kometen in der Ortsschulwolke stoßen zufällig zusammen, dann bricht ein Stück ab.
Wovon geht man aus? Wie viel Masse da in dieser Wolke so versammelt ist?
Die Gesamtmasse weiß ich jetzt nicht auswendig, aber man schätzt so, dass da wirklich so ein paar zehn, zehn Milliarden Kometen schon da in der Gegend ungefähr herumschwirren.
Wenn man die jetzt so alle zusammenpackt, könnte man da so eine Erde draus bauen? Oder ist das irgendwie weniger oder ist das ja viel mehr?
Also ich finde, der Gesamtmaß ist jetzt schwer zu sagen. Da müsste ich jetzt irgendwie lügen, wenn ich eine Zahl sage. Aber ich schätze, wenn ich das vergleiche mit der Masse, die im Asteroidengürtel ist und im Kuipergürtel, also im Asteroidengürtel ist es halt so ein bisschen so eine Mondmasse ungefähr, im Kuipergürtel ist es so ein bisschen Erdmasse. Also in der Ortsschulbolke würde ich schon deutlich mehr, deutlich mehr, also würde man deutlich mehr als eine Erde rauskriegen.
Und ist das dann das Ende? Also ist da irgendwie unser Sonnensystem beendet?
Also da ist eine ganz klare Grenze, wie so ein Ortsschild, sondern ein System Ende. Das gibt es nicht.
Schöner mit so einem roten Balken irgendwie.
Also die Ortsschulbolke ist schon, das ist auch nicht so eine Kugelschale, wie so eine Kuppel, darf man sich das auch nicht vorstellen. Das ist quasi so ein Bereich, der wirklich von, bei 10.000 astronomischen Einheiten anfängt und so bis 100.000 astronomischen Einheiten geht, also wirklich ein extrem langer Bereich, lang gestreckter Bereich.
Was ist eine astronomische Einheit?
Das ist der Abstand zwischen Erde und Sonne. Das ist so die Standard-Einheit, wenn man sich im Sonnensystem bewegt.
Und die Ortsschirrwolke ist wie viel astronomische Einheit?
Ja, also die fängt halt, die inneren Bereiche, die inneren Bereiche stellt man sich an, stellt man sich vor, dass die so bei ein paar 1.000 astronomischen Einheiten ungefähr anfangen. So 1.000 AU, sowas in der Gegend, 1.000 astronomische Einheiten. Und der äußerste Rand der Ortschirrwolke ist halt irgendwie so bei 100.000 irgendwo in dem Bereich rum. Also es ist ungefähr der Abstand, die Hälfte zum nächsten Stern. Also wenn wir von hier zu Alpha Centauri gehen, dann ist die Ortschirrwolke ungefähr bei der Mitte ungefähr zu Ende. Also wenn wir mit einem Raumschiff zu Ortschirrwolke, zum Ende der Ortschirrwolke fliegen, dann haben wir schon die Erlüfter der Strecke zu Alpha Centauri zurückgelegt. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt auch keine klare Grenze, wo es jetzt zu Ende ist und wo nicht. Und man kann vermutlich noch der Einfluss der Sonne selbst vielleicht sogar noch ein Stückchen weiter. Je nachdem, wie stark dann die Gravitationskraft noch mehr ist.
Also wenn ich das richtig ausrechne, müsste so das Licht dann gut ein anderthalb Jahr unterwegs sein.
Das kommt hin, ja. Alpha Centauri ist vier Lichtjahre weg, grob geschätzt, und dann Ortschirrwolke zwei Lichtjahre, also so der Drehraum, eineinhalb bis zwei Lichtjahre ungefähr.
Das ist ja schon ganz schön weit draußen. Jetzt gab es ja Erkundungs-Satelliten, die Voyager, Voyager 1 und Voyager 2. Das waren meines Wissens die einzigen, die jetzt wirklich so das Ziel hatten, mal so das ganze Planeten-System entlang abzuklappern.
Haben die auch geschafft, ja.
Die waren ja erstaunlich erfolgreich.
Die sind immer noch erfolgreich. Voyager 2 fliegt ja immer noch herum.
Eins nicht mehr. Also fliegen tun sie wahrscheinlich beide noch.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie jetzt die Kommunikation mit den anderen läuft.
Die sind ja zeitgleich gestartet worden.
Genau.
Und haben dann aber unterschiedliche Bahnen genommen, je nachdem, wie man sich am besten durchhangelt und Schwung holt. Und beide haben jetzt quasi aber schon den eigentlichen, ja, man sagt immer, sie haben das Sonnensystem verlassen. Sind sie jenseits dieser ortschen Wolken schon?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Die Voyager 1 und 2, die sind jetzt quasi, haben hinter, die Neptune-Bahn, die haben die Neptune-Bahn verlassen und sind jetzt quasi auf dem Bereich, auf dem Weg hinter die Neptune-Bahn. Also die, bis zur ortschen Wolke, da brauchen die noch ein paar tausend Jahre. Also wenn man jetzt meint, sie haben das Sonnensystem vergessen, dann verlassen, dann meint man damit so halt den, das Planeten, genau, den Planetenbereich. Oder diesen sogenannten Termination-Shock, wo halt die Strahlung der Sonne, also die Teilchen, die der Sonnenwind, die die Sonne auszündet, auf den Interstellaren, das Material im Interstellarenraum trifft, wo es dann quasi so eine Schockwelle gibt. Und dieser Bereich wird eben auch oft als eine der vielen Grenzen des Sonnensystems bezeichnet. Und da ist eben auch eine von den Voyager-Sonden, glaube ich, vor ein paar Jahren mal durchgeflogen.
Was passiert da genau?
Also die Sonne sendet nicht nur Licht aus, sondern auch Teilchen. Jedes Mal, wenn es eine Protuberanz oder so ist.
Der Sonnenwind.
Genau, es ist der Sonnenwind.
Und das, was sich so in den Nordländern dann als Auroren liegerschlägt.
Genau, wenn es aufs Machtnetfeld, genau, auf dem Mariefel, die Erde trifft, dann gibt es dann Nordlicht. Und diese Teilchen des Sonnenwinds, die treffen irgendwann auf, die gehen einfach weg. Und im Bereich zwischen den Sternen, es ist nicht nichts, sondern da ist, natürlich ist da für unsere Maßstäbe ist da nichts, aber es ist auch ein bisschen halt einfach ja interstellares Medium, nennt man das. Es ist einfach halt die weiße Material, was zum Beispiel bei Supernova-Explosionen irgendwo rausgeschmissen worden sind, ist einfach halt so Zeugs halt, Gas, kleine Teilchen. genau, wenn der Sonnenwind auf dieses insere Medium trifft, dann gibt es eine Art Schockwelle, wo es sich so ein bisschen aufstaut.
Aber warum trifft es denn erst da, da drauf? Ich meine, es müsste ja eigentlich überall auch innerhalb unseres Sonnensystems da drauf prallen.
Das ist, ja, unser Sonnensystem, da ist ja wieder, da, das ist ja quasi von dem, von dem Sonnenwind, also je näher mal die Sonne kommt, desto stärker ist quasi der Bereich freigeräumt, weil der Sonnenwind da ist da dauernd von der Sonne wegschüttet.
Wegspült sozusagen. Also unser Planetensystem ist so quasi freigespült von diesem Interstellaren Zeug.
Genau.
Kann man das so sagen.
Sonst wäre es nicht Interstellar, genau. Es gibt auch ein Interplanetaris-Medium und es ist wieder eine andere Geschichte. Es gibt auch ein intergalaktisches Medium. Da wird es aber wieder kompliziert. Ja, und wie gesagt, diesen Bereich hat eben auch die Voyager-Sonde, ich weiß nicht, ob es eins oder zwei war, ich glaube zwei, auch eben einmal...
Das hat sie gemessen oder ist das nur so, dass man der Meinung ist, dass sie da so sei?
Nee, die haben auch schon ein bisschen was gemessen. Also die können auch ein bisschen Teilchen messen. Also was die genau gemessen haben, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber man hat da schon noch ein paar Messungen auch angestellt.
Das heißt Voyager 1 ist nicht mehr zu empfangen?
Das kann ich jetzt... Ich weiß auf jeden Fall, dass Voyager 2......noch funkt.
Also funken tun sie noch beide, also Kraft haben sie eigentlich noch, bloß ist es schwierig, das Signal zu empfangen.
Ja, man hat auch letztes Mal bei Voyager 2, gab es bei der Geschichte, dass irgendwo die Pilz-Zeitung wieder geschrieben hat, dass Voyager 2 von Aliens entführt worden ist, weil sie plötzlich irgendwie nicht mehr das, was irgendwie komischen Kram gesehen hat, den keiner verstanden hat. Also das, was Voyager 2 geschickt hat, hat niemand mehr verstanden. Das war irgendwie komisches, verschlüsselter Kram. Und natürlich hat da ein Pilz-Zeitungsexperte gemeint, okay, vielleicht haben Aliens die Sonde entführt oder so was. Warum die dann irgendwie die Sonde umprogrammieren, dass sie komischen Kram sendet, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Aber wenn es einfach so ist, es gibt eine kosmische Strahlung...
Da sind Aliens einfach.
Ja, aber es gibt kosmische Strahlung, es sind einfach energiereiche Teilchen von den Sternen, von der Galaxie, die halt durchs All fliegen. Und wenn du irgendwie so ein kosmischer Strahlungszeichen hast, das dir gerade blöd auf deinen Computerteil der Chip trifft und irgendwie in der 1 zu einer 0 umdreht oder sowas, was durchaus passieren kann, dann kriegst du halt komischen Kram raus. Und mittlerweile haben die Leute es auch halt so softwaremäßig ein bisschen überbrückt von der Erde aus. Und jetzt können die das auch wieder verstehen, was die Sonne sagt. Also läuft alles wieder normal.
Das heißt, die beiden, die fliegen jetzt irgendwie einfach bis Ultimo und irgendwann kommen sie mal irgendwo an oder nicht?
Oder auch nicht, ja. Aber sie fliegen dann einfach weiter. Wenn sie jetzt nicht irgendwo mal auf irgendwas draufprallen und die Chance ist gering, weil im Weltall, grob gesehen, ziemlich viel Platz ist, fliegen die halt einfach...
Ist das jetzt noch interessant, was die da einsammeln? Kann man da noch irgendwelche Erkenntnisse erwarten?
Doch, doch, interessant ist das immer. Prinzipiell mal interessant ist zu sehen, wenn man die Sonde empfängt, die Signale, dann weiß man ja auch, wo sie ist. Man weiß ja, man muss ja erstmal die Antenne genau ausrichten und die Laufzeit kann man ja genau ausrechnen, wo das Ding gerade ist. Und hier kann man auch wieder das gleiche Spielchen machen wie mit dem Planeten, mit dem Merkur und mit Nepton vorhin. Also man kann irgendwie ausrechnen, wo muss die Sonde sein, wenn man die ganzen Gravitationskräfte berücksichtigt und die Antriebskräfte oder sowas, und wo ist sie wirklich? Also ist die Sonde dort, wo sie sein soll.
Aber woher weiß man denn, wo sie wirklich ist?
Weil ich die Messungen habe. Ich habe ja kommuniziert mit der Sonde. Ich weiß, ich habe von dort das Signal empfangen, also muss sie dort gewesen sein.
Die Richtung kriegt man so genau bestimmt?
Ja, das kann ich aus der Laufzeit des Signals genau sagen. Und ich kann auch, wenn ich die Antenne ausrichte, ich muss die genau auf die Sonde ausrichten, sonst höre ich ja nichts. Und wie gesagt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Abweichungen habe zwischen der Position der Sonde, wo sie sein sollte, und wo sie ist, dann ist das durchaus interessant. Es gibt ja die sogenannte Pioneer-Anomalie. Wenn man die Sonden ganz weit rausgeht aus dem Sonnensystem, also wenn die jetzt in den Bereich äußerer Sonnensysteme oder hinter einer Neptumbahn kommen, dann hat sich gezeigt, dass die Sonden alle eine komische Abweichung haben. Die sind alle nicht dort, wo sie sein sollen. Man weiß aber irgendwie nicht, man weiß bis jetzt immer noch nicht genau, woran es liegt. Man hat sich gedacht, okay, vielleicht ist da irgendwo noch mehr Asteroid im Körper, als wir gedacht haben, dass die Anziehungskraft 100 stärker ist. Aber das war es irgendwie nicht wirklich. Man hätte vielleicht gedacht, dass irgendwie die, vielleicht irgendwas im Antriebssystem von der Sonne irgendwie nicht so wirklich läuft, wie man sich gedacht hat. Aber das war es eigentlich auch nicht so. Man weiß noch nicht genau, was da jetzt irgendwie los ist. Also es kann zum Beispiel auch sein, es kann wirklich irgendwas ganz Banales sein. Also wirklich einfach irgendwie einen technischen Effekt, den man noch nicht irgendwie rausgekriegt hat, den man übersehen hat bis jetzt. Oder es kann wirklich etwas ganz Dramatisch-revolutionäres sein. Dass man wirklich einfach noch ein anderes Gravitationsgesetz braucht. Also dass das Realitätstheorien nicht so funktioniert, wie man dachte, dass man noch was ganz Neues braucht. Also das ist irgendwas, wo immer noch dran gearbeitet wird. Und solche Sachen sind durchaus interessant zu wissen. Und darum ist es auch gut, dass die Sonden, auch wenn die sonst nichts mehr viel tun, es reicht einfach nur, dass sie fliegen und ab und zu mal Pieps machen und dann sagen, wo sie sind. Also das ist auch schon wahnsinnig interessant für die Wissenschaft.
Gibt es denn da neue Projekte? Haben wir noch mal vor, noch mal sowas zu starten?
Es ist jetzt zum Beispiel gerade eine Sonde unterwegs, die nennt sich New Horizon. Das ist das schnellste Objekt überhaupt, das bis jetzt von Menschen irgendwie losgeschickt worden ist. Also die ist von New Horizon gestartet. Ich bin immer so schlecht mit Jahreszahlen. New Horizon müsste, ich glaube, 2000 rum. Ich weiß es echt nicht. Es ist eine Sonde, die ist unterwegs, Pluto. Pluto ist das einzige größere Objekt im Sonnensystem, was noch nicht besucht worden ist. Also die Voyager- und Pioneer-Sonden, die sind nicht bei Pluto vorbeigekommen. Darum haben wir von dem Ding immer noch kein vernünftiges Bild. New Horizon soll eben Pluto besuchen. Wird 2015, glaube ich, an Pluto vorbeifliegen. Also in den Orbit um Pluto reinschwenken, das klappt nicht, weil das Ding ist so wahnsinnig schnell. Wenn es bei Pluto angekommen ist, dass man da enorm viel Kraft bräuchte, um es wieder abzubremsen, und so viel Treibstoff hat man nicht dabei. Das heißt, es wird wirklich nur an Pluto vorbeifliegen, und halt im Vorbeifliegen Aufnahmen machen, und dann fliegt es weiter in den Kuipergürtel und guckt nach, was dort so los ist.
27.000 Kilometer Entfernung soll es dann haben. Ne, 9600 Kilometer Pluto und 27.000 Kilometer Entfernung zu Charon. 2006 gestartet worden. Und 2015 schon da, also weniger als zehn Jahre.
Das ist verdammt schnell. Man sich überlegt, wie lange die anderen Sonden dafür gebraucht haben, um irgendwie die Voyager- und Pioneer-Sonden herauszukommen.
Wodurch ist das Ding so schnell?
Ja, Voyager ist in den 70er Jahren gestartet worden. Also mittlerweile hat man dann doch bessere Antriebstechniken rausgekriegt. Aber die Details vom New Horizons Antrieb, da bin ich auch überfragt. Also da müsste man irgendwie in Raumfahrt-Technik fahren. Und es gibt auch eine zweite Sonde, die halt, dass es nicht jetzt ins äußere Sondensystem geht, sondern eine, die auch im Asteroiden-Hauptgürtel zu Ceres fliegt. Die wird auch so im 2014, glaube ich, solidar sein. Die heißt Dawn. Dawn müsste die heißen, ja. Und das sind wirklich interessante Dinge. Also dann werden wir auch über die Asteroiden mehr wissen. Und vor allem auch über den Pluton, über den Kuipergürteln. Das wird wirklich spannend.
Gibt es denn dann auch so viel Unklarheiten?
Ja, Unklarheiten nicht, aber was die Asteroiden angeht, wir haben sehr viel entdeckt. Entdeckt haben wir Hunderttausende. Aber die Dinger sind so klein, dass ich selbst mit einem großen Teleskop, kriege ich im Prinzip nur einen Lichtpunkt raus. Mit einem großen Teleskop, mir von der Erde aus, kann ich schon Sachen, kann ich irgendwelche Wolkenbänder auf Jupiter erforschen oder Mars-Oberflächenstrukturen sehen. Auf einem Asteroid, selbst von Pluto oder sowas, wo er wieder groß ist, da sehe ich im Prinzip nichts. Wenn ich da wirklich was Näheres wissen will, dann muss ich hinfliegen. Die Asteroiden sind ja wirklich alle weit weg, sind weiter weg als der Mars, die im Hauptgürtel zumindest, und die im Kuipergürtel noch weiter. Und sind auch schwierige Ziele, weil so ein Asteroid ist halt sehr klein, auf so einem kleinen Ding mit wenig Schwerkraft, kann man schlecht landen. Wenn jemand was runter schickt, dann prallt es gleich wieder ab. Da muss man sich technisch anspruchsvoller Missionen dorthin zu fliegen. Da wissen wir noch wenig. Wir haben ein paar Aufnahmen von Raumsonden, die zum Beispiel zu Jupiter geflogen sind oder weiter raus, die vorbeigeflogen sind an Asteroiden. Bis jetzt gerade nächsten zwei Wochen, ich glaube am 13. Juli, fliegt die Rosetta-Sande an einem Asteroiden vorbei. Die will da zu einem Kometen, und auf dem Weg kommt sie an Asteroiden vorbei. Das wird auch eine ziemlich interessante Sache. Es gibt ein paar andere Raumsonden, die schon ein bisschen näher an Asteroiden vorbeigekommen sind. Es gibt ein paar, wo wir direkt zu einem Asteroiden geflogen sind. Zum Beispiel gab es die, die hieß Eros, oder war das der Asteroid Eros, zu dem sie geflogen sind. Da ist man auf einem Asteroid gelandet und hat den näher untersucht. Da konnte man wirklich genau Sachen sehen. Und jetzt, letztes Wochenende am Sonntag, da war eine spektikuläre Sache, da ist die japanische Mission, Hayabusa, die ist zu einem Asteroiden hingeflogen, dort hat eine Landeinheit abgesetzt, hat dort Bodenproben genommen, ist wieder zurück zur Erde geflogen und hat diese Bodenproben dort abgeworfen. Das heißt, man hat diesen Probenbehälter gefunden. Ich weiß jetzt noch nicht, ob der schon analysiert worden ist, ob die jetzt wirklich auch verwerbbares Material gefunden haben. Wenn das geklappt hat, dann wäre das wirklich beeindruckend, wenn man das erste Mal wirklich konkrete Proben von einem echten Asteroiden hat. Wir haben auf der Erde zwar jede Menge Meteoriten, aber da ist irgendwie so etwas übrig geblieben, nachdem der ganze Rest in der Atmosphäre verbrannt ist. Da hätten wir das erste Mal wirklich vernünftige Proben von Asteroiden. Wie gesagt, Asteroiden sind nicht nur generell interessant, die sind auch interessant, weil sie halt das Material sind, aus dem die Planeten entstanden sind. Das ist das ursprüngliche Material, aus dem unser ganzes Sonnensystem entstanden ist. Insofern sind die Dinge enorm interessant.
Kommen wir vielleicht mal zurück zu unserem Sternensystem. Wir haben ja schon über die ein oder anderen Planeten ein bisschen was erzählt. Was ist denn so der interessanteste Planet von uns an? Ich meine, das ist immer eine sehr relative Geschichte, was jetzt interessant ist und was nicht interessant ist. Aber man hat so den Eindruck, am meisten stürzt sich eigentlich alles schon immer. Und in den letzten Jahren im Besonderen auf den Mars.
Ja, also wie gesagt, es kommt drauf an, wie man interessant definiert. Wenn man aus einer außenstehenden Perspektive sagen müsste, dann wäre natürlich die Erde, auf der Erde ist am meisten los. Da gibt es Lebewesen, das ist einwahrlich. Du wirst jetzt in unserem System, dass es da Leben gibt. Aber für uns Menschen natürlich, wir kennen die Erde, die ist jetzt nicht so interessant. Wir haben jetzt zumindest was astronomisch gesehen. Und da ist der Mars natürlich das ideale Ziel, weil der Mars ist nahe an der Erde dran, zwar nicht so nahe wie die Venus. Aber die Venus ist halt, da ist es verdammt heiß. Da sind die Bedingungen extrem mies. Also wenn ich da eigentlich eine Raumsonde hinschicke und die landen dort, dann sind die extrem schnell kaputt, weil die Bedingungen so extrem sind dort. Und der Mars, das ist eben wirklich, der ist auch indelt der Erde sehr. Also ich habe dort ein bisschen Atmosphäre, zwar eine extrem dünne, aber immerhin ein bisschen. Ich habe dort ein bisschen Temperaturen, die vergleichbar sind mit der Erde. Also wenn es warm ist am Mars, dann hat es da so 20 Grad vielleicht. Und ansonsten ist es halt auch im Jahr, kann es natürlich auch extrem kalt werden, aber es ist jetzt nicht vergleichbar mit irgendwelchen minus 200 Grad, die es irgendwann in Pluto hat, oder irgendwie plus 500 Grad, die es irgendwo anders hat. Ja, das ist auch einerseits für die Technik leichter zu verkraften. Andererseits eben auch, wenn wir wissen wollen, wie wir auf der Suche nach anderen erdähnlichen Planeten sind, ist das interessant. Und der Mars ist halt deswegen ein ideales Ziel und auch, weil er immer noch vermutlich einer der besten Plätze ist, wenn wir wissen wollen, ob es irgendwo anders mal Leben gegeben hat oder Leben gibt im Sonnensystem.
Was ist denn der Stand der Dinge? Wasser ist gefunden worden?
Wasser ist gefunden worden. Wir wissen, dass es früher am Mars jede Menge Wasser gab und auch offenes Wasser gab, so wie auf der Erde im Prinzip. Wir wissen, dass es heute noch Wasser gibt. Zumindest auf jeden Fall in gefrorener Form. Und vielleicht kann es ab und zu auch sein, dass es je nachdem, wenn es kurzfristig flüssig wird, und es gibt Bilder, Aufnahmen vom Mars, wo man sieht, wo es außen das Wärtshörsel von einer Sandbühne ein bisschen was runtergetröpfelt hat, dass Wasser heute kurzfristig flüssig werden kann. Es ist noch nicht ganz klar, wie das abläuft.
Aber ich meine, wenn es 20 Grad hat?
Ja, es hatte nicht immer diese Temperatur. Wasser ist auch im Boden drin. Es ist tief im Boden gefroren. Da muss es erst mal irgendwie rauskommen. Aber wir wissen, dass es da Wasser gibt. Und vor allem, wenn es früher Wasser gegeben hat, dann könnte es früher durchaus leben gehen können. Und vielleicht hat zumindest eine Migranten, primitiv als Bakterien-Einzelne, auch heute noch irgendwo überlebt. Es gibt ja diese kleinen Dinger, die können ja auch auf der Erde in extremsten Umgebungen leben. Also vielleicht gibt es ja Mars auch, aber wirklich verbindliche, konkrete Ergebnisse gibt es noch nicht. Da haben wir mit den ganzen Sonden, die wir uns hingeschickt haben, zu jeder Menge Hinweise gefunden, dass es möglich ist, aber noch nichts definitives festzustellen kann. Da muss man noch weiter suchen. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch andere Möglichkeiten. Also es kann auf Titan zum Beispiel so etwas geben. Da sind die Bedingungen zwar anders als auf unserer Erde und auf Mars, aber es gibt dort Möglichkeiten, dass es auch primitives Leben gibt.
Also Titan ist ein Mond des Saturn.
Genau, ein Mond des Saturn, wo auch schon eine Raumsonde gelandet ist. Es gibt auf Europa, das ist ein Mond von Jupiter. Da vermutet man mit ziemlicher Sicherheit, dass es dort unter dem großen Eispanzer, der den ganzen Mond überzieht, ein Ozean gibt, also wirklich flüssiges Wasser, in dem sich theoretisch Leben entwickeln hätte können. Aber dass da wirklich hinfliegen und irgendwie ein Loch in den Panzer bäumen und irgendwie ein U-Boot reinschicken, dass man das rausfindet, das wäre technisch vielleicht sogar möglich, aber halt sehr aufwändigend, sehr teuer zu finanzieren, also es wird so schnell nicht passieren. Es gibt schon einige Möglichkeiten, wo man Leben finden könnte im Sonnensystem, aber am Mars ist es natürlich am einfachsten zu suchen, und darum sucht man halt hauptsächlich dort.
Diese Suche nach Leben bestimmt ja eigentlich, also habe ich zumindest den Eindruck, bestimmt so ein bisschen den aktuellen Trend, das ist so ein bisschen...
Nicht wirklich, das ist vielleicht eher der Eindruck, den man von den Medien bekommt, weil die Medien sich hauptsächlich sich für die Suche nach Leben interessieren, weil es ist nicht irgendwie so die Suche nach ausländischem Leben, es ist natürlich ein tolles Thema, was man super verkaufen kann, was man super erzählen kann, was auch alle interessiert. Aber die Wissenschaftler selbst, also die sind genauso begeistert von einer Mission zu Neptune wie zu einer Mission zum Mars. Also es ist alles interessant, jeder Planet ist interessant und alles, was wir, egal welchen Planeten, herausfinden, bringt uns weiter. Natürlich ist es die Suche nach Leben für uns als Mensch interessant, weil wir wissen wollen, ob wir auf der Erde hier die einzigen Lebewissen sind oder ob es Leben auch anderswo gab. Also es ist eher so eine philosophische Komponente, das Ganze noch mal so ein bisschen so ein Sahnehäubchen, was uns das Ganze extra interessant macht, aber rein vom wissenschaftlichen Ding her ist die Suche nach Leben zwar durchaus ein Thema, was interessant ist in der Wissenschaft, aber bei Weitem nicht das, was alles dominiert. Also die Themenauswahl wird doch auch noch jede Menge andere Faktoren...
Was würdest du denn sagen, gibt es überhaupt ein dominantes Thema in der Wissenschaft rund um die Planeten und das Universum, was jetzt wirklich vorherrschend ist?
Im Prinzip ist es auch so wie überall anders, gibt es immer auch so Modethemen. Themen, die quasi eine Zeit lang in Mode sind und wo dann viel dran gearbeitet wird. Aber ich würde sagen, es hängt einfach immer davon ab, wie jetzt gerade die technischen Mittel sind. Die Suche nach extrasolaren Planeten zum Beispiel, nach Planeten, die nicht in die Sonne kreisen, die hat man auch in den 70er und 80er Jahren gemacht. Aber damals war es wirklich ein extremes Minderheitenthema, weil halt von der Beobachtungstechnik her absolut so gut wie nichts möglich war. Man hätte da schauen können, wohin man wollte, wie lange man wollte. Man hätte vermutlich nichts gefunden. Aber seit eben unsere Technik so gut geworden ist, dass wir die Dinge wirklich sehen können, wird es natürlich überall geforscht, wie wild. Und es ist immer mehr und immer mehr. Und drum ist halt gerade die extraplaneten Forschung momentan ein sehr dominierendes Thema. Wenn wir dann jetzt zum Beispiel in zehn Jahren oder so was neue Raumsonden haben, die vielleicht mal Gravitationswellen zum Beispiel nachgewiesen haben und wir fähig sind, mit Gravitationswellen irgendwas vernünftiges anzustellen, dann wird vielleicht das Thema irgendwie extrem dominant werden. Also es ist immer, man arbeitet dort, wo es gerade gut geht. Also man kann jetzt nicht so konkret festlegen, dass das jetzt irgendwie ein Thema jetzt gerade alles andere dominiert.
Okay, dann versuche ich mal ein bisschen anders aufzurollen. Nein, du bist ja Astronom, so abgesehen davon, dass du jetzt in deinem Blog irgendwie alles, was jetzt gerade sowieso passiert, in irgendeiner Form thematisiert, weil es ja auch spannend ist. Man muss ja auch mal breit gucken, ganz klar. Ist ja im Computerbereich jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel anders. Aber an was arbeitest du denn? Was zeigt dich denn jetzt sozusagen? Gibt es da irgendeine Spur, die du verfolgst?
Also was ich jetzt im Moment gerade arbeite, das sind auch Exoplaneten. Ich bin Himmelsrechaniker und mein Thema sind die Bewegung von Himmelskörpern, Asteroiden und Planeten. Und in dem Fall interessieren mich natürlich auch die Exoplanetensysteme, gerade weil die Beobachtungen noch nicht gut genug sind. Ich bin kein beobachtender Astronom, ich bin ein Theoretiker. Und wenn man keine Beobachtungen machen kann, dann muss man sich halt irgendwie überlegen, was man aus der Theorie rausholen kann für Informationen. Und zum Beispiel ist es so, dass manche Planeten entdeckt werden durch sogenannte Transits. Ein Transit ist, wenn ein Planet vor einem Stern vorbeigeht. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel von der Erde aus auf die Sonne gucken, dann kann es passieren, dass wenn die Planeten gerade richtig stehen, aus unserer Sicht aus die Venus vor der Sonne vorbeiläuft. Also wenn wir die Sonnenscheibe anschauen, sehen wir einen kleinen schwarzen Punkt, der da dran vorbeiläuft, das ist die Venus. Und sowas kann auch bei anderen Stellen passieren. Wenn wir jetzt einen Stern anschauen von der Erde aus und der Stern am Planeten hat und wir Glück haben und gerade auf die richtige Art und Weise draufblicken, dann kann dieser Stern quasi den am Stern vorbeilaufen. Und während der vor dem Stern steht, verdeckt er ein kleines Stückchen von dem Stern. Das heißt, der Stern wird ein winzig kleines bisschen dunkler und das kann man messen. Man kann quasi, wenn man das Licht von dem Stern misst und dann sieht, ok, der Stern wird ein regelmäßigen Abstände schwächer, dann kann man da ausrechnen, ob es da einen Planeten gibt und welche Eigenschaften der hat. Und auf diese Art und Weise sind schon viele Planeten entdeckt worden.
Vor allem in den letzten Jahren.
Genau. Und natürlich ist es umso einfacher, je größer der Planet ist. Weil je größer ist, desto mehr deckt er ab. Jetzt wäre es natürlich auch schön, wenn man mit der Methode zum Beispiel Planeten finden könnte, der so groß wie die Erde ist, weil die sind ja die, die uns noch fehlen. Wir kennen die ganzen kleinen Planeten, die haben wir noch nicht entdeckt. Aber das ist halt schwierig, weil das gerade noch an der Grenze der aktuellen Technik ist. Aber was man machen kann, ist quasi indirekt über die Theorie gehen. Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel wissen, dass da ein Planet Transit macht, dann wissen wir, okay, der braucht jetzt einmal um den Stern herum, braucht er, sagen wir mal, zehn Tage, dann wissen wir, okay, alle zehn Tage muss es so eine Verdunkelung geben von dem Stern.
Woher weiß man, wie lange der für seine Umlaufbahn braucht?
Das kann man messen. Also, wie gesagt, ich messe ja die, ich messe das Licht vom Stern, dann sehe ich, okay, da wieder am 1. April wieder Schwäche, am 10. April wieder Schwäche, am 20. April wieder wieder Schwäche. Das heißt, ich kann wirklich sehen, wie der Abstand ist zwischen den einzelnen Verdunklen.
Okay, aber zu den Zeiten hast du den Planeten ja schon entdeckt.
Ja, nein, das war schon fertig. Also, ich muss jetzt quasi den, ich habe jetzt quasi mal erstmal von den Erobachtungen aus dem natürlich mein Modell. Ich sage, okay, wenn ich jetzt einen Planeten habe, welche Eigenschaften muss der Planeten haben, um genau das zu erzeugen, was wir beobachtet haben? Und dann bekomme ich eben ein Modell. Dann bekomme ich eben einen Planeten, der die und die Eigenschaften hat. Jetzt kann es natürlich sein, dass mein Modell nicht ganz stimmt. Ja, wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt einen zweiten Planeten im System habe, den ich vergessen habe zu berücksichtigen, dann kann es sein, dass der ein bisschen diese Bahn von dem einen Planeten stört. Das heißt, dann kommt der manchmal ein bisschen früher oder ein bisschen später an bei dem Stern und dann würde das ein bisschen abweichen von meinem idealen Modell, das ich habe. Und wenn ich solche Abweichungen habe, dann kann ich quasi so einen zweiten Planeten finden in dem System, ohne ihn direkt sehen zu müssen. Also ich kann einfach nur durch die Abweichungen, die ich habe, von meinem idealen Fall herausfinden, ob es da einen zweiten Planeten gibt oder nicht.
Also ähnlich jetzt wie die Geschichte mit dem Neptun.
Richtig, genau. Und was ich quasi mache, ist eben auch von den bekannten Sternen und den Planeten, die ich jetzt hier dran sitze machen, probieren, auszurechnen, was für Möglichkeiten es da gibt. Also wenn wir jetzt einen Stern haben und ich stelle mir vor, ich habe ja noch einen zweiten Planeten, so groß wie die Erde, was hätte der für einen Effekt? Also welchen Effekt würde der erzeugen? Und kann man den Effekt beobachten oder nicht? Wenn der jetzt irgendwie gerade groß genug ist, dass man ein theoretisches Schimpfdiskop sehen könnte, dann kann der Beobachter hergehen und kann genau nachschauen, ob der Effekt jetzt da ist oder nicht. Das ist einfacher, als wenn man es quasi blind drauf lossucht. Und dann muss man quasi einfach alles anschauen und alles mögliche absuchen. Da ist es einfacher, wenn man eine konkrete theoretische Vorhersage hat, die schon mal von der Theorie her Einschränkungen macht und sagt, was prinzipiell möglich ist und was nicht. Und das ist eben das, was ich gerade probiere zu machen, also solche Vorhersagen von solchen Transitzeitvariationen.
Das heißt, du musst aber dann auch schon mit beobachtenden Astronomen zusammenarbeiten?
Das natürlich. Auch wenn man selbst nicht Beobachtungen macht, die Theorie muss ja trotzdem irgendwie mit der Realität übereinstimmen. Das heißt, man muss immer den Kontakt zu den Beobachtern haben, wenn man sonst an der Realität vorbei forscht.
Wie sieht denn so ein Kontakt aus? Vielleicht können wir ja mal ein bisschen mehr auf diese konkrete astronomische Tätigkeit zu sprechen kommen. Abgesehen jetzt von dem Theoretiker, der sich jetzt nur in sein Büro einsperrt und im Internet surft, bzw. seine Berechnung macht. Und dann gibt es ja dann auch immer gleich so dieses Bild, dass sie da irgendwie so in Chile, in den Anden irgendwie mit ihren Teleskopen rum sitzen, wo irgendwie kein Staub in der Atmosphäre klebt, der einem irgendwie den Blick verstellt. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen übertrieben. Aber wie läuft so diese nationale, internationale Zusammenarbeit?
Also wenigstens in meinem konkreten Fall. Ich überlege mir zum Beispiel zuerst mal, wie jetzt dieses Problem, die Berechnung dieser komischen Variationen, wie ich das machen soll. Dann mache ich mal ein paar Testfälle, also wo ich einfach irgendwelche Fälle ausdenke, einfach nur zu schauen, ob die ganze Methode funktioniert. Also bevor ich irgendwas Konkretes machen kann, muss das Ding ja erst mal theoretisch funktionieren. Wenn das mal alles so läuft, wie es ungefähr laufen soll, dann denke ich mir, ok, zum Beispiel dann rufe ich jetzt einen Kollegen an, von dem ich weiß, dass der jetzt von der Beobachterseite her sich mit solchen Sachen beschäftigt. Also einer, der zum Beispiel jetzt hier in Gena wird das gemacht, auf der Sternworte in Großschwarbhausen, das ist ein Dorf in dem an, da machen die genau das. Also da beobachten die Sterne und gucken, ob die heller oder dunkler werden und probieren aus diesen Transits Planeten zu finden. Dann rufe ich den Kollegen an und sage mir, ok, ihr habt jetzt gerade einen interessanten Stern, von dem ihr Transitmessungen macht und wollt ihr wissen, welche Variationen es da geben würde, wenn es noch andere Planeten gibt. Und dann, je nachdem, dann macht man halt Vorschläge, welche Sterne gerade interessant sind, welche sie interessieren würden. Dann kriege ich da konkrete Daten von denen, die oft, meistens sind ja immer die publizierten Daten, da gibt es dann auch schon oft neuere Daten, die halt auch nicht publiziert worden sind, die man dann direkt in Kontakt bekommt. Dann stecke ich die in mein Programm rein, dann schaue ich, was da rauskommt, dann treffen wir uns mal, diskutieren darüber, reden darüber und so ist das quasi jetzt hier im kleinen Rahmen, wie es abläuft. Im internationalen Gruppensammenarbeit, da ist es halt so, im Prinzip so wie bei jeder anderen Wissenschaft auch. Also man kommuniziert da hauptsächlich was über Publikationen und Konferenzen, wo halt dann sich die Leute, die am gleichen Thema arbeiten, sich zusammenfinden. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass da ständig der eine mit dem anderen telefoniert. Das kommt schon vor, aber es ist meistens doch eher, dass quasi jede Arbeitsgruppe, es gibt lokale Arbeitsgruppen an den Unis, wo gearbeitet wird, und die tun sich dann thematisch irgendwie mit anderen abstimmen. Also das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so, dass es da große Unterschiede zu anderen Wissenschaften gibt in der Astronomie.
Dein besonderes Interesse geht der Himmelsmechanik. Genau. Also dabei eben auch extra solare Planeten, aber auch die Asteroiden. Was ist denn mit der großen Gefahr, dass die Erde nochmal von so einem Asteroiden durchlöchert wird?
Die Gefahr ist auf jeden Fall da. Also wir wissen, dass in der Vergangenheit Asteroiden mit der Erde kollidiert sind. Wir wissen, dass es heute noch passiert. Jeden Tag fallen ein paar Tonnen Material aus dem All auf die Erde runter. Das meiste davon ist irgendwie Kleinkram, also Staub oder Mikrometeoriten. Jeder Sternschnuppe, den ich im Himmel sehe, ist im Prinzip ein Asteroid, ein minzig kleiner Asteroid, ein paar Millimeter groß, der mit der Erde zusammenstößt.
Ein paar Millimeter groß macht schon eine richtig sichtbare Sternschnuppe?
Genau, ja. Die Sternschnuppen sind so kleine Staubkörner, die zusammenstossen in der Atmosphäre. Und es gibt ab und zu, so alle halbe Jahre oder so was, liest man in den Medien von einem Feuerball, der irgendwo exportiert ist oder so was im Himmel. Das sind also größere Objekte, die sind ein Zentimeter, Meter groß ungefähr, die in der oberen Atmosphäre auseinanderbrechen. Also wir wissen, dass auch heute noch ständig Material mit der Erde zusammenstößt. Und im Prinzip ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis auch mal wieder ein größeres Objekt mit der Erde kollidiert. Also es ist nicht die Frage, ob es passiert, sondern eigentlich nur die Frage, wann es passiert. Ich will jetzt keine große Panik verbreiten hier oder sowas. Dafür gibt es keinen Grund. Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die Zeiträume zwischen so großen Kollisionen, wenn wir jetzt die Dinosaurier hernehmen, das war ja wie so ein 10-Kilometer-Brocken, der da runtergekommen ist. Also da sind die Zeiträume wirklich, es sind zwischen solchen Kollisionen liegen.
Das ist jetzt gesicherte Erkenntnis mit dem Dinosaurier.
Ja, gesichert ist nie was 100-prozentig.
Aber es ist auch schon nachgewiesen, dass das Ding da bei Mexiko...
Genau, es ist nachgewiesen, dass da genau zu der Zeit ein Asteroid ein großer eingeschlagen ist. Und die Fachkräfte streiten sich noch, ob der Asteroid alleine war oder ob da noch in den Vulkanen beteiligt war. Aber dass da ein Asteroid eine wichtige Rolle gespielt hat, das ist fix. Ja, und solche großen, sichere Megaeinschläge, die passieren, statistisch gesehen, relativ selten. Aber wie soll das mit Statistik sein? Ich kann genau aus gutem Morgen einer kommen, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering. Das Wichtigste an der ganzen Sache ist, dass man wirklich...
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist deshalb gering, weil man mittlerweile so gut beobachtet.
Genau, auf das wollte ich jetzt gerade kommen. Wir wissen, je größer die Objekte sind, desto leichter sind sie zu entdecken. Mittlerweile haben wir schon sehr, sehr viele Asteroiden entdeckt. Und man schätzt, dass man wirklich von den Dingern, die über einen Kilometer groß sind, dass wir da schon so 95 Prozent aller Objekte in unserer Nähe gefunden haben, die es gibt.
Ab wann wird es dann gefährlich?
Kommt darauf an, wie man gefährlich definiert. Also wenn du gerade irgendwie ein kleines Ding auf dem Kopf fällt und du tot bist, dann war es für dich gefährlich, aber für alle anderen nicht.
Da sagen wir mal, was wäre in der Lage, so eine Stadt komplett zu pulverisieren?
Ja, 1908 gab es in Sibirien ein Ereignis, der berühmte Tunguska-Meteorit, der wirklich große Flächen verwüstet hat. Also wenn der über Berlin, das Tunguska-Eigens in Berlin passiert wäre, nicht in den Sibirischen Tiger, wäre vielleicht Berlin nicht pulverisiert, aber auf jeden Fall doch gewaltiger Schaden angerichtet worden. Und das Ding in Tunguska, wie groß war das? Das war so 60 bis 80 Meter ungefähr. Also das war jetzt doch...
60 bis 80 Meter und es ist doch im Wesentlichen nur ein Felsbrocken.
Im Prinzip, ja.
Was entwickelt dann diese ungeheuer Kraft?
Naja, dieser Felsbrocken ist wieder ein Felsbrocken, aber ein verdammt schneller Felsbrocken, also mit ein paar 20 Kilometer pro Sekunde oder so was unterwegs. Und wenn der lang in die Erdatmosphäre reingeht und plötzlich abgebremst wird, dann muss die ganze Energie von der Bewegung irgendwo hin. Und man kann sich das wirklich so vorstellen, in Tunguska so, da war jetzt irgendwie ein Objekt, das mit der Erde kollidiert ist, in die Atmosphäre eingetreten ist und dann so ein paar Kilometer über dem Erdboden auseinandergebrochen ist, wodurch plötzlich statt einem großen Objekt viele kleine waren. Das heißt, die Gesamtoberfläche der Objekte hat sich von einem Moment auf dem anderen extrem erhöht, weil sich mehrere kleine Objekte eine größere Oberfläche haben als ein großes. Wodurch sich die Reibungshitze extrem stark erhöht hat von einem Moment auf dem anderen und das ganze Ding explodiert ist. Das war im Prinzip vergleichbar wie wenn ich eine Atombombe nehme und dann ein paar Kilometer über der Oberfläche explodieren lasse. Der ganze Druck geht nach unten drum. Es gibt diese tollen Bilder von Tunguska, wo wirklich Tausende Millionen Bäume wirklich alle gefällt worden sind, von der Druckwelle umgeblasen worden sind. Und wie gesagt, so ein Ereignis wie in Tunguska, von der Statistik her, kann sowas, gibt es auch wieder unterschiedliche Schätzungen, aber so alle paar tausend Jahre oder sowas, alle paar hundert bis tausend Jahre schätzt man das, dass man das so auftreten kann. Das Wichtigste ist eben, man kann es jetzt, wenn es am Asteroidenabwehr und sowas besorgt ist, da ist es erstmal nicht so wichtig, dass man sich hier ein bisschen Pläne aller Prosphilie oder sowas ausdenkt, sondern das wirklich das Wichtigste ist, den Himmel zu beobachten. Weil, wenn wir was tun wollen, und das Interessante ist, wir können was tun, wir könnten theoretisch was machen gegen den Asteroiden, der ankommt. Aber damit wir irgendwas tun können, müssen wir Bescheid wissen vorher. Wenn wir jetzt wissen, übermorgen kommt einer, dann brauchen wir nichts zu machen. In der Zeit kann man keine Abwehrmaßnahmen einleiten. Wir müssen vorher Bescheid wissen. Je länger, desto besser.
Aber man kann ausrechnen, wo er niedergeht? Wie?
Nicht mal das wirklich. So grob, vielleicht so die Hemisphäre oder so die groben Kontinenten oder sowas. Aber wenn man genau wissen will, wo er runterkommt, dann muss er wirklich so bis ein paar Stunden vorher oder sowas Bescheid wissen.
Ein paar Stunden vorher wüsste man, dass er in Berlin runtergeht.
Genau, das hängt immer vom Spezialfall ab. Es hängt davon ab, wie er zusammengesetzt ist. Wenn es ein reiner Eisenmeteorit ist, dann geht er gerade durch und schlägt ein. Wenn es etwas leichteres ist, aus Eis und Gestein vielleicht zusammengesetzt, dann bricht die Atmosphäre aufeinander. Dann ändert sich wieder die Flugbahn und so weiter. Das kann man wirklich so...
Okay, das heißt, richtig gefährlich sind eigentlich nur die, die auseinanderbrechen? So ein Eisenteil, der geht einfach nur durch und macht ein Loch?
Ja, ein Eisen ist noch gefährlicher, weil der viel mehr Masse hat. Wenn der in der Atmosphäre auseinanderbricht, dann müssen wir Glück haben. Wenn es ein großes Ding ist, das aber nur aus Eis und Gestein besteht, dann haben wir vielleicht Glück. Und der bricht voll genau auseinander, sodass die Bruchstücke nicht mehr allzu viel Schaden anrichten. Aber wenn da ein großes Eisending runterkommt, die sehr selten sind, dann hat es eine extreme kinetische Energie. Und die haben wir dann direkt im Erdboden drin. Also Eisen, Meteorite sind immer, die muss man nicht haben.
Das ist dann so wie Erdbeben.
Naja, wenn so ein Meteorit runterkommt, ein großer, dann ist das alles auf einmal. Du hast einen Erdbeben, du hast eine riesengroße Druckwelle, du hast eine Feuerwelle, die sich ausbreitet rasend schnell.
Die Feuerwelle kommt durch die Erhitzung, einfach durch die Reibung mit der Erdatmosphäre.
Das ist einfach extrem viel Energie, wie eine Explosion, die spontan frei wird. Du hast Staub, der in die Atmosphäre aufgewibbelt wird, der dann wieder als sauer Regen runterkommt. Du hast Verdunkelung. Wenn es nach dem, wie groß es ist, kann es sein, dass du ein paar Jahre lang keinen richtigen Sommer hast. Das Ding wie Tsunamis, wenn ein Wasser runterkommt. Das Asteroid ist so ein Best-of von allen Naturkatastrophen.
Will man einfach nicht haben. Best-of.
Und wie gesagt, damit man das vermeiden kann, muss man früh genug Bescheid wissen. Und nach Möglichkeit Jahre vorher, Jahrzehnte, je mehr, desto besser. Wenn man den Asteroid diese Kollision vermeiden will, dann muss man die Bahn von dem Ding ändern.
Okay, nehmen wir jetzt mal an, da wäre so ein Teil. Das ist 500 Meter im Durchmesser, das ist schon so ein bisschen beunruhigend. Oder? 500 Meter ist beunruhigend. Und der Tor gehört jetzt irgendwie rum, und es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass er auf uns niedergeht. Ja, aber was würde man denn da tun? Auf den Boden legen und schreien?
Ja, also bei 500 Metern, das ist jetzt kein so ein...
War das schon so apokalyptisch?
Nee, nee, also 500 Meter ist kein Zivilisationskiller. Also bei 500 Meter, das wäre jetzt nicht so ein Weltuntergang à la Bruce Willis, wo die ganze Erde dran glauben müsste.
Wie hieß dieser Film noch? Ich hab den nicht gesehen.
Deep Impact, Armageddon. Nee, gab zwei. Bruce Willis war Armageddon.
Aber der hat mal einfach Bruce Willis hochgeschickt und der hat das Ding irgendwie weggeschickt.
Ja, Bruce Willis war die Kino-Variante, die spektikulär ist, aber die einzige, die eigentlich nichts bringt. Also das Ding hochfliegen, das Ding in die Luft sprengen. Das war der Taktik, also in welche Löcher reinbohren und dann wegsprengen. Also das bringt nichts.
Warum?
Weil ich dann statt eigen ganz großen Dingen mehrere große Dinge hab, die trotzdem noch auf die Erde fallen.
Wie sozusagen an der Flugbahn endet das irgendwie nicht viel.
Genau, da müsste es wirklich so stark sprengen, dass es wirklich nur noch kleine Krümel sind. Und dafür sind die Dinge einfach zu groß. Das sind ja selbst so 500 Meter Felsbrocken, das ist ja doch was Großes. Also das, was man machen muss, ist die Bahn ändern. Also man muss einfach die Bahn ein bisschen ändern oder vielleicht ein bisschen abbremsen oder beschleunigen. Wenn ich den ein bisschen bremse, den Asteroid, dann kommt er später an und dann ist die Erde schon weg. Oder ich beschleunige ein bisschen, dann ist er früher da und die Erde ist noch nicht da. Das ist einfach nur ein bisschen schneller oder langsamer machen. Und wenn ich das früh genug weiß, wenn ich das irgendwie 5 Jahre vorher weiß oder 10 Jahre vorher weiß, dann reicht es schon, wenn das eine ganz winzige Änderung ist. Weil es sich im Laufe der Zeit sicher...
Das heißt, was würde man machen? Man würde irgendwie erstmal alle Satellitenlaunches aussetzen, den nächsten Slot sich holen und dann schnell so ein Gerät bauen, was auf dem Teil landet?
Also wenn wir erstmal von der Idealsituation ausgehen und das jetzt nicht irgendwie die ganzen Regierungen anfangen zu streiten, wer jetzt was zu machen hat und so weiter... Dann würde man sich überlegen, wie man jetzt, je nachdem... Also erstmal müsste man das Ding genau beobachten. Also wenn man sich das mal legen, rausfinden, ist es ja das Eisen, ist es das Stein. Man müsste jetzt vermutlich erst mal...
Muss ich das überlegen? Kann man das bestimmen?
Das kann man natürlich machen, aber das kann man noch nicht einheitlich sagen. Also man würde auf jeden Fall mal so schnell es geht eine Raumsender los schicken, die direkt dorthin pflegt. Das ist vermutlich das erste, was man machen würde. Einfach wirklich ein Ding hinschicken, das dorthin fliegt zu den Asteroiden. Am besten drauf landet.
So ein Teil, das so einen Speed hat wie dieses New Horizons.
Ja, vielleicht noch schneller, je nachdem.
Wäre die wirklich so signifikant schneller als das Teil selber? Ach so, es ist ja nicht gesagt, dass er nicht direkt auf uns zu fliegt, sondern er zieht so seine Bahnen?
Genau, er zieht seine Bahnen. Dann treffen wir uns und kreuzen sich unsere Bahnen. Das ist nicht so wie eine Pistolenkugel, die gerade auf uns zu fliegt. Also wir schicken da ein Ding hin. Und da wird man erst einmal genau wissen, was für ein Ding wir zu tun haben. Und dann wird man sich überlegen, wie man das jetzt am besten bremsen oder beschleunigen kann. Also da gibt es viele Möglichkeiten. Vielleicht reicht es aus, dass ich da einfach eine Raumsunde hinschieße, die irgendwie da festmache, und dann mit einem fetten Triebwerk hinten dran einfach Gas gebe. Zum Beispiel. Das ist ganz simpel, einfach wegschieb das Ding. Oder man kann probieren, eine Atomrakete hinschicken, Atombombe, die aber nicht jetzt irgendwie im Asteroiden zünden oder auf dem Asteroiden, sondern wirklich vor dem Asteroiden, dass die Druckwelle ein bisschen bremst, also das Seite schiebt. Das kann auch funktionieren. Oder man kann auch nicht noch, man kann da irgendwie ein großes Sonnensegel dran festmachen, zum Beispiel.
Die Druckwelle im Vakuum des Weltalls, wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Ja, du kannst das, wenn du quasi von dem Asteroiden, kannst du ja auch irgendwie so ein Ding abschießen. Du nimmst dir den Asteroiden her und schießt den auf den... Entschuldigung, ich hab jetzt zu Davies einen Fehler gemacht. Die Mission, die ich gemeint hatte, war jetzt nicht mit der Druckwelle, sondern das war die... ach Gott, den hab ich jetzt zweiteinander gebracht. Ich meinte die Donkey-Shot-Mission. Aber die hat mit dem anderen Ding...
Das ist ja egal, es geht ja jetzt darum, den richtigen Ansatz zu finden. Wir wissen, es wird uns irgendwann umhauen, das ist aber noch irgendwie 5-6 Jahre hin. Das ist eine realistische Voraussage. Also könnte man jetzt mal so hypothetisch so... Wenn man ein Kürbchenkürbchen muss machen, ja. So, dann schlägt er irgendwie mächtig ein. Wo er einschlägt, wissen wir nicht. Aber das Ding ist irgendwie so groß und so finsterschwer, dass es gut sein kann, dass er halt irgendwie, was weiß ich, Disneyland irgendwie platt macht. Und das geht natürlich gar nicht. Und die Amerikaner sind irgendwie schon komplett... offen. Sozusagen schon in voller Montur und müssen jetzt unbedingt was tun. Und dann fliegt man jetzt hin. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Atombombenzünden davor. Da hab ich mich jetzt einfach nur gewundert. Meinst du schon, das würde was bringen?
Es kommt auf das Objekt wirklich drauf an. Also ob es jetzt irgendwie von der Zusammensetzung her, von der Masse her, wenn es jetzt ein ziemlich großes, schweres Objekt ist, dann wäre es ja die Atombombe auch nicht weiter beeindrucken lassen. Dann wär es zum Beispiel klüger, wenn man da jetzt irgendwie zum Beispiel einen Sonnensegel dran festpappt. Es gibt auch konkrete Pläne, dass man da hinfliegt. Dann irgendwie an dem Ding verankert, so ein Sonnensegel, so ein riesengroßes, ein paar Quadratkilometer großes Ding zum Beispiel, oder ein 100 Quadratmeter großes Ding, so eine dünne Folie, die den Teilchen vom Sonnenwind auffängt. Wenn das so ein geladenes Teilchen vom Sonnenwind auf diese Folie trifft, gibt es einen Impulsübertrag und eine Kraft und man kann im Prinzip mit einem Sonnensegel so segeln wie mit einem Segel bei einem Segelschiff. Also weiß man, dass das funktioniert, dass sich das Sonnensegel tatsächlich auch Raumfahrzeuge bewegen können. Das haben wir jetzt gerade erst wieder getestet. Wenn man das früh genug macht, dann kriegt man wirklich über fünf Jahre hinweg einen konstanten Druck auf das Segel drauf, der den Asteroid so langsam zur Seite schiebt. Das könnte man machen. Oder man könnte den Asteroid zur Hälfte weiß anmalen. Das würde auch funktionieren, wenn man sich überlegt, dass der Asteroid zum Beispiel das Licht von der hellen und dunklen Fläche anders reflektiert, wodurch es auch wieder zu einem leicht anderen Kräfteverhältnis auf den verschiedenen Seiten kommt, wo da auch ein bisschen abgelenkt wird.
Also durch die Farbe werden andere Kräfte ausgewirkt?
Ja, es geht darum, wie das Licht reflektiert wird und wie die Temperatur ist. Es gibt einen Unterschied. Der Strahlungsdruck hängt auch unter anderem von der Temperatur mit ab, wie das Objekt hat. Wenn ich eine asymmetrische Temperaturverteilung auf dem Asteroid schaffe, indem ich eine Hälfte zum Beispiel weiß anmale oder mit dem anderen weißen Reflektin als Material, dann kann ich wirklich eine Kraft erzeugen. Ich erzeuge nicht eine Kraft, sondern die Kraft des Strahlungsdrucks, die Kraft des Sonnenwinds, wirkt unterschiedlich stark an den unterschiedlichen Hälften. Das sind minimale Kräfte, wirklich minimal. Aber wenn die über lange Zeit hinweg aufrechterhalten werden, dann kann es wirklich reichen, um diese kleine Bahnänderung durchzuführen, die ich brauche, damit der Asteroid die anderen nicht trifft. Oder es gibt noch eine, meine Lieblingsvariante ist ja quasi die für das Kino ungeeignetste. Man baut ein sehr, sehr großes, sehr, sehr schweres Raumschiff und fliegt hin und macht nichts. Das könnte aber funktionieren, weil jetzt so ein großes, schweres Raumschiff ist groß und schwer und hat eine Masse und die Massen ziehen sich nicht an. Und wenn jetzt irgendwie der Asteroid klein genug ist, dann könnte diese Masse vom Raumschiff, wenn ich das auf die richtige Art und Weise am Asteroiden quasi parke, an die richtige Stelle, dann zieht die Masse des Raumschiffs den Asteroid ein bisschen an und lenkt ihn ab.
Großes, schweres Raumschiff im Sinne von...
Das hängt wieder vom genauen Spezialfall ab. Aber man hat das Ganze durchgerechnet und gezeigt, dass es wirklich auf die Art und Weise einfach möglich ist, eine relevante Kraft auf den Asteroid auszuwirken, sodass er halt abgelenkt wird. Also wie gesagt, für das Kino halt untauglich. Irgendwie, Bro Spillis fliegt ins Alum, macht ja schon nix. Das schäte ich keinem mehr an. Aber in der Praxis, in der Praxis, in der Praxis, in jeden Fall Wichser.
No Impact. Ja, das wäre wirklich ein Blockbuster. Cool, einfach so ein bisschen Gravitation ausüben sozusagen.
Das könnte ja vielleicht so ein finnischer Regisseur trainieren, schwarz-weiß oder so.
Ja, genau, einfach so das totale Nichts. Das wäre eigentlich was für Kubrick.
Es gibt Methoden, wie man so eine Asteroidenbahn verändern kann. Gibt es viele. Wir haben keine noch konkret ausprobiert. Das wissen wir noch nicht, wie das gehen soll. Aber wir wissen, wir haben Ideen, wie es gehen könnte. Und wenn wir früh genug Bescheid wissen, dann kriegen wir es weiter hin.
Und glaubst du, dass sich dann auch alle irgendwie ausreichend einigen würden? Du hast ja vorhin schon so gesagt, na ja, wenn sie sich irgendwie nicht gegenseitig hauen.
Ja, das ist halt schwierig. Wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, wie die Politik weltweit zustande ist, dann wenn es nicht zufällig gerade nächste Woche passiert und nächste Woche Wahl ist oder so was, sondern wenn es erst in 10 Jahren ist.
Muss man sich denn so groß einigen? Im Prinzip könnte man ja mehrere Methoden gleichzeitig vorbereiten.
Ja, das Ding ist halt, so was ist halt Raumfahrt. Raumfahrt ist teuer. Und vor allem solche Missionen, das ist ja nicht so einfach ein Lied ins All schicken, sondern da muss man wirklich irgendwie zu einem anderen Planeten hin fliegen, zu einem Asteroiden weg fliegen, der weit weg ist, dort wird man auch landen oder irgendwie komplizierte Sachen machen dort. Und solche Missionen, wenn sie für wissenschaftliche Dinge gemacht werden, da wird oft jahrzehntelang geplant. Also da fängt man irgendwie... Es gibt zum Beispiel Missionen, das Herrschulteleskop zum Beispiel, das ist einfach nur ein Teleskop, das ins Weltall muss und nicht mal irgendwo kompliziert hin fliegen und landen. Das hat man irgendwie angefangen, in die 80er Jahre zu planen, bis es dann irgendwie 2009 endlich losgeflogen ist. Also solche Dinge brauchen viel Planung, brauchen viel Geld und wie gesagt, wenn man das jetzt irgendwie schnell machen will, dann muss man wirklich da auch viel investieren, damit es auch wirklich, man kann natürlich einfach auf gut Glück irgendwas hinschicken und denken, vielleicht wird schon passen, sondern man muss es halt wirklich schnell und gut irgendwas hinkriegen und das ist halt immer teuer, da braucht man viel Geld und viel Infrastruktur, viel Ressourcen und da es ist vermutlich dann, wenn es nur ein einzelnes Land macht, wird es nicht reichen, wenn man sich anschaut, die Amerikaner, was wollen die machen? Die haben jetzt nicht mal mehr irgendwelche Shuttles, die sie losfliegen lassen können, also die sind nicht mal mehr, ab Ende des Jahres sind sie nicht mal mehr fähige Menschen ins All zu bringen. Also ob sie dann irgendwie jetzt allein in eine Asteroiden-Abwehr-Mission hinkriegen, ich denke mal so was kann wirklich dann nur noch international funktionieren.
Na gut, bloß für das muss man ja jetzt nicht unbedingt da hinschicken. Ist der da selber irgendwie gelandet?
Ja, der war irgendwie so ein Ölboer-Typ, glaube ich. Der war ja der beste Öl- bzw. mit Bohrungen der beste, weiß ich, ausgekannte, ist mit seinem Team da hingeflogen und hatte irgendwelche Löcher in Asteroiden gebohrt, irgendwelche Atombomben reingesteckt und ist in die Luft gejagt.
Na ja, ich glaube, die Ölindustrie wird uns nicht retten, macht zumindest derzeit irgendwie nicht so richtig den Eindruck. Diese Kometen, die haben wir ja schon irgendwie angesprochen, wie unterscheiden die sich? Also ich meine, ein Komet ist im Prinzip nur ein Asteroid, der einfach auf die schiefe Bahn geraten ist. Kann man das so sagen, oder gibt es da noch irgendwie andere Aspekte?
Ja, es gibt schon unterschiedliche Aspekte. Ein Komet ist das Ding mit dem Kometenschweif. Also ein Komet besteht zu einem großen Teil auch aus gefrorenem Material. Also ein Komet ist quasi eine Mischung aus Stein und Eis. Und ein Komet hat sehr viel gefrorenes Material. Aber in seiner Oberfläche oder generell, kann man sich so vorstellen, wie wenn jetzt so ein Matschhaufen im Winter so Kieselsteine und Schneematschen alles zusammenpappelt. So was ist ungefähr. Und dann jetzt irgendwie tieffriere das Ganze. Dann habe ich einen Kometen ungefähr. Das war so ein Ball aus Stein und Eis und Schmutz und Staub und Gas.
Aber warum hat der so viel Wasser auf einmal?
Weil der Komet die meiste Zeit sehr weit weg ist. Die Asteroiden im Hauptgürtel zum Beispiel sind alle relativ nahe an der Sonne. Sie kriegen da auch viel Strahlung ab. Und das verpflichtet so den Lauf der Zeit. Man kann es auch wirklich sehen, es gibt auch einige Zwischendinger, Objekte, die eigentlich Asteroiden sind, aber ab und zu mal doch noch ein bisschen Material ausstoßen, wo man denkt, das sind vielleicht ehemalige Kometen, die alles, was sie an flüchtigem Material haben, was sie ihm abgeben können, schon fast alles abgestoßen haben. Wenn so ein Komet, so ein gefrorenes Ding, von weit draußen reinkommt, dann sieht er die meiste Zeit so aus wie ein Asteroid, bis er nahe genug an die Sonne kommt. Irgendwo in der Gegend von Jupiter ungefähr ist das. Und dann die Sonne anfängt, ihn langsam aufzuwärmen, aufzutauen. Dann wird das ganze flüchtige Material, das ganze Eis, das ganze Gefrorene, löst sich dann ab, erzeugt diesen großen Kometenschweif. Durch dieses wegfliegende Eis werden viele Staubpartikel von der Oberfläche mit abgerissen. Und das verteilt sich dann entlang der Bahn des Kometen. Und diesen großen Staubschweif ist eben das, was den Kometen im Sichtbau ausmacht, den Sichtbau von dem Asteroiden unterscheidet. Aber je öfter der um die Sonne rumkommt, desto mehr Material verliert er auch. Und irgendwann ist es dann so, dass der entweder, je nachdem wie nah er an die Sonne rankommt, entweder der löst sich überhaupt komplett auf. Das heißt, der bröckelt dann quasi immer mehr ab und ab, bis er irgendwann mal bei der Sonne nicht mehr vorkommt und verschwunden ist. Oder er widdert einfach zu einem dunklen Felsbrocken, der sich nicht weiter von dem Asteroiden unterscheidet.
Der aber trotzdem auf dieser komischen schiefen Bahn ist und da dann auch ewig so weiter rumzirkelt.
So lange halt, bis er nicht mit irgendetwas zusammenstößt. Diese aufgelösten Kometen sind auch der Grund für die Sternschnuppen. Für die meisten Sternschnuppen. Es gibt ja diese Sternschnuppenschauer, wo man sagt, im August gibt es die Leoniden, die Perseiden und so weiter, diese verschiedenen Sternschnuppen-Schrömer, wo man mit den Medien immer hört, die nächste Woche sind wieder extrem viele Sternschnuppen. Das ist immer genau dann, wenn quasi die Erde die Bahn von so einem Kometen kreuzt. Der hat entlang der Bahn die ganzen Krümel liegen gelassen, die abgebröckelt sind im Laufe der Zeit. Wenn die Erde diese Staubspur durchkreuzt, dann sehen wir diese Staubkörnchen, die in der Atmosphäre glühend sind, das sind die ganzen Sternschnuppen. Man kann viele von diesen Sternschnuppenströmen konkreten Kometen zuordnen.
Wie viele Sternschnuppen hast du schon gesehen in deinem Leben?
Oh Gott, ich habe nicht mitgezählt. Einige, viele. Im Prinzip reicht es, wenn man sich irgendwo einen klaren Abend sucht und am Himmel schaut. Auch wenn es gerade nicht Sternschnuppenschauerzeit ist, man sieht fast immer irgendwas. Ein bisschen Staub fliegt immer rum.
Zischt einfach die ganze Zeit.
Wenn man zumindest eine gute Nacht mit Leoniden oder Perseiden findet, dann können es wirklich auch Hunderte sein in der Nacht. Das Problem mit der Lichtverschmutzung, was man überall hat, dass man in den Städten, in den Ballaxrahmen fast nichts mehr sieht. Das heißt, man kann froh sein, wenn man einen Stern sieht. Sternschnuppen braucht man gar nicht mehr denken.
Um jetzt diese Beobachtung wirklich zu machen, da haben wir früher das klassische Teleskop gehabt. Heute hält man sich das nicht mehr direkt ans Auge. Da sind riesige Apparate. Was ist denn mittlerweile für eine Infrastruktur am Start, um das alles zu beobachten?
Wir haben die klassischen Teleskope, die immer größer und größer geworden sind. Früher waren es Linsenteleskope. Und dann seit Newton, der die ersten Spiegelteleskope so entwickelt, dass sie auch brauchbar waren. Das war schon mal der erste Fortschritt, weil man im Spiegel wesentlich größer bauen kann als eine Glaslinse. Dadurch sind diese Spiegelteleskope immer größer und größer geworden. Wir haben die großen Teleskope in Chile und Hawaii stehen, bis zu 10 Meter große Spiegel, mit denen es sich schon extrem viel machen lässt. Was man heutzutage macht, ist, wenn wir jetzt nur auf der Erde bleiben, Weltraum-Teleskope sind eine andere Sache, wenn wir auf der Erde bleiben, haben wir immer das Problem mit der Atmosphäre. Ich kann mein Teleskop noch so riesengroß bauen, wenn ich schlechte Bedingungen habe in der Atmosphäre, dann sehe ich nichts bei der Atmosphäre. Es sind ja verschiedene Luftschichten, die immer so ein bisschen hin und her waren, und wird dadurch diese ganze Auflösung zerstören. Und da hat man in den letzten Jahren, Jahrzehnten adaptive Optiken entwickelt. Das heißt, man hat da quasi so einen Sensor, im Prinzip so einen Laserstrahl, der einfach in den Himmel zielt. Und der Laserstrahl kann messen, wie die Atmosphäre jetzt quasi so gerade so ein bisschen wie die jetzt flackert, wie die sich verändert. Und diese Informationen werden direkt in Echtzeit über einen Computer an den Spiegel, den Teleskop-Spiegel weitergeleitet. Und dieser Spiegel ist kein ganzes, kompaktes Stück, sondern ein Beispiel aus vielen einzelnen kleinen Spiegeln, die man verändern kann, die man verbiegen kann. Also ich kann den Spiegel quasi an beliebig vielen Stellen leicht verbiegen.
Wie so ein Facetten-Auge?
So ungefähr, ja. Und die einzelne Facette kann ich ein bisschen hin und her biegen. Und wenn jetzt von einem Stern, normalerweise kommt das Licht von einem Stern, kann man sich vorstellen, wie es in eine ganz gerade Wellenfront, die auf den Spiegel trifft. Durch die Atmosphäre wird diese gerade Wellenfront jetzt verzerrt. Und das ist eben das, was man die Bilder dann schlecht macht. Wenn jetzt aber ich messen kann, wie die Linie genau verzerrt ist und ich den Spiegel dann genau auf die gleiche Art und Weise verforme, dann kann ich quasi genau diese Verzerrung ausgleichen und bekomme wieder ein gutes Bild. Und genauso macht man es mit der adaptiven Optik. Das heißt, die Optik misst automatisch immer, wie quasi die Verzerrung gerade aussieht, stellt den Spiegel entsprechend ein. Und so kann ich eben bessere Bilder bekommen, als ich sie mit einem normalen Teleskop bekomme. Dann kann ich diese atmosphärischen Störungen ausgleichen.
Und das ist jetzt nur bei den ganz großen Teleskopen, die jetzt so in Schiele stehen, oder was? Die stehen ja sowieso schon in so Bereichen, wo es eigentlich relativ wenig Luftverschmutzung gibt, oder?
Das geht nicht nur von der Luftverschmutzung selbst her, sondern einfach von der, diese atmosphärischen Störungen kommen ja auch durch die Temperatur und das Schiel zum Beispiel, oder durch Wind oder was weiß ich. Also alles, was halt die Luft, sobald die Luft sich bewegt irgendwie, habe ich diese atmosphärischen Störungen mitgebracht.
Aber warum stehen die jetzt in Chile und nirgendwo anders? Was ist da jetzt so besonders gut?
Da ist es zum Beispiel, erstmal stehen die weit weg von allem anderen, was irgendwie störendes Licht erzeugen würde. Genau. Das ist der erste Punkt. Dann natürlich auch von Luftverschmutzung und so weiter her. Also da ist auch einfach kein Dreck in der Atmosphäre, kein Smoke oder sonst irgendwas. Und dann ist es wichtig, dass das Wetter gut ist. Also es bringt nichts, wenn ich mir jetzt irgendwie einen Millionen-Teurist-Gruppe irgendwo hinstelle, hier im Thüringer Wald, wo es irgendwie die Hälfte des Jahres regnet. Also ich brauche irgendwo eine Gegend, wo es nicht regnet. Und da sind eben drumstehende Dinge auch irgendwie in den ganzen Wüsten rum. In der Atakama-Wüste in Chile oder irgendwo in der Wüste von Arizona oder sonst wo. Also ich muss irgendwo sein, wo das Wetter möglichst gut ist.
Also in seltenen Wolken sind. Genau.
Also in Chile hat man wirklich über 300 Tage im Jahr klaren, wolkenfreien Himmel. Was eben auch natürlich ein Grund ist, warum man dorthin geht.
Und die Höhe?
Die Höhe auch eben natürlich klar. Je weiter oben ich bin, desto weniger Störungen in der Luft habe ich, die mir meine Bilder irgendwie stören können. Das ist ja bei den Bergen genauso. Also wenn ich auf dem Berggipfel bin, sieht man auch immer die Wolken unter sich. Und genau das will man auch irgendwie bei den Teleskopen haben, dass die Wolken unter einem sind.
Und die Dinger sind dann irgendwie komplett digital?
Es gibt automatische Teleskope. Meinst du jetzt mit digital?
Ich frage mich, wie gewinnt man jetzt sozusagen die Bilder? Es ist ja nicht so, dass man die ganze Zeit da einer sitzt und guckt, ob ihm was auffällt. Sondern man will das ja eigentlich permanent aufzeichnen und permanent auswerten.
Genau, man geht natürlich nicht einfach hin um solche großen Teleskope. Man geht einfach hin und denkt, heute gucke ich mal, was ich so finde. Sondern die Beobachtungsnächte sind für jedes Jahr komplett ausgeplant, ausgebucht. Das heißt, man muss wirklich einen Antrag schreiben und die größte der Anträge wird abgelehnt. Nur wenn man wirklich gute Vorschläge macht, was man beobachten will, bekommt man überhaupt Beobachtungszeit. Und oft kann es auch nur sein, dass man nur eine halbe Nacht bekommt. Die Vergabe ist wirklich streng dort.
Das heißt, sie haben überhaupt kein Problem, ausgelastet zu sein?
Das Problem ist, Zeit zu kriegen auf diesen Teleskop. Da muss man einfach nur sagen, ich möchte mal das angucken und gucken, ob es interessant ist. Da muss man wirklich genau wissen, was man machen will. Man muss genau sagen, ich will den Stern beobachten und zwar mit dem Teleskop und genauso lange und mit dem Filter und mit dem Gerät usw. Man muss vorher ganz genau sagen, was man machen will. Und wenn es dann genehmigt wird, dann geht man hin und macht das. Und dann gibt es dann wirklich Techniker dort, die haben das einstellen und man selbst geht auch noch hin und überprüft das Ganze. Und dann muss man irgendwie, je nachdem, welches Teleskop es ist, es gibt jetzt Teleskope, die komplett im automatischen Modus betrieben werden. Das heißt, da sitzt man hier in Deutschland vor dem Computer und stellt das ein. Es gibt Teleskope, die im Service-Modus betrieben werden, wo wirklich nur ein Techniker sagt, was man machen will und der macht das für einen. Und dann gibt es eben auch welche, wo man selbst hingeht, weil man das auch konkret vor Ort auf Entscheidungen treffen muss, je nachdem, wie das Wetter ist, ob man das nicht machen kann, wenn man das Alternativprogramm macht und so weiter. Und wie gesagt, man hat eben nicht wirklich viel Zeit, da jetzt groß rumzusuchen, rumzuschauen. Das heißt, es wird vorher alles festgestellt, da wird genau das aufgenommen, was man haben will. Das wird alles digital gespeichert. Das sind alles Computerbilder, die gespeichert werden. Und dann im Prinzip, wenn man beobachtet, fährt man und macht nichts anderes, man macht nur Aufnahmen.
Was haben die denn für eine Auflösung, diese Bilder, die man da bekommt?
Ach Gott, das hängt wirklich ganz vom Teleskop selbst drauf ab. Also da hängt wirklich davon ab, welches Teleskop man jetzt genau benutzt.
Also ich stell mir jetzt nur gerade so vor, dass das mega maximal groß auflösende Bilder sind, oder stell ich mir das schon wieder zu sophisticated vor?
Also die Rohdaten, die man hat, hängen wirklich davon ab. Also es gibt auch oft, dass man wirklich jetzt nicht immer ein Bild macht, sondern halt einfach nur Fotometrie. Das heißt, dann macht man nur die Helligkeit. Da macht man jetzt irgendwie kein Foto, sondern nur ein Spektrum. Da kriegt man auch kein Bild, sondern nur halt die spektrale Verteilung der Energie und so weiter. Also man hat einfach, man erzeugt, wenn man beobachtet ist und die Bedingungen gut sind, so viel Daten wie noch irgendwie geht, also da wird keine Sekunde verschwendet, wird alles an Daten erzeugt, was noch geht, alles auf irgendwelche CDs, DVDs, USB-Sticks gepackt. Und dann erst, wenn man zu Hause ist, dann wird das Ganze ausgewertet. Also beim Beobachten wird wirklich nur so viel Daten produziert wie möglich.
Und die Teleskope, die nicht auf der Erde stehen?
Genau, da läuft es im Prinzip auch so. Also auch beim Hubble-Teleskop oder den anderen großen Weltraum-Teleskopen, da muss man genauso Beobachtungsanträge stellen. Ich kann jetzt irgendwie als Astronom sagen, ich möchte mit Hubble dieses und jenes beobachten. Dann muss ich einen Antrag schreiben, muss den da zu der Organisation hinschicken, zur NASA, und die entscheidet dann genauso wie bei den Teleskopen in Chile, ob das jetzt irgendwie sinnvoll ist, was ich machen will, und ob das jetzt irgendwie gerechtfertigt ist, dass ich das Teleskop benutze. Und dann natürlich kann ich es nicht selbst an dem Teleskop rumfuschen und das hin- und herschwenken. Das machen dann schon die Techniker, aber ich kann denen genau sagen, was ich beobachten will. Dann machen die das und schicken die Daten einfach zugeschickt.
Was kann man...
Der Vorteil an den Weltraum-Teleskopen ist, dass...
Keine Atmosphäre.
Genau, da hat man überhaupt keine Störungen in der Atmosphäre. Ich kann viel, viel, viel bessere Bilder machen, ohne dass ich mit kleineren Spielen, mit kleineren Auf- und Geräten... Und das ist der Vorteil. Der Nachteil ist, dass die Dinger... Man kann mal nicht eben so mal hinfahren, wenn man kaputt ist und reparieren. Das heißt, wenn es kaputt ist, ist es kaputt und dann ist es auch verdammt aufwendig, das Ding zu reparieren. Also man muss nicht mit dem Special hinfliegen und so weiter. Wie es bei Hubble war, Hubble war ja kaputt, wie es geschadet worden ist, hat ja nicht richtig funktioniert. Und dann war es wirklich enorm aufwendig, das Ding zu reparieren. Aber es hat sich gelohnt, wie man gesehen hat. Aber das ist halt der Nachteil wieder, was man in der Weltraumastronomie hat, dass die Geräte wesentlich, wesentlich teurer sind.
Der Einfluss von Hubble war aber dann doch extrem groß, oder? Also der Erkenntnisgewinn allein durch den Betrieb von Hubble?
Hubble, also man kann jetzt nicht genau in Zahlen ausdrücken, wie relevant Hubble für die Astronomie war, aber es gibt fast keinen Forschungsbereich in der Astronomie, der durch Hubble nicht irgendwie beeinflusst worden ist. Ob es jetzt Planetologie ist oder Extrakalaktik oder Exoplaneten oder Asteroiden, also Hubble hat alles beobachtet und überall fantastische Bilder gebracht, die besser waren als viele, die man von der Erde her kannte. Also Hubble war für die gesamte Astronomie extrem wichtig. Und ist es immer noch. Hubble ist ja noch da und beobachtet ja noch. Ja, es gab jetzt vor kurzem erst auch die letzte Service-Mission letztes Jahr. Hubble selbst hat jetzt vor ein paar Monaten den 20. Geburtstag gefeiert. Und man hofft, dass ein paar Jahre sollte Hubble noch durchhalten. Aber dann irgendwann ist halt auch die Möglichkeit der Reparatur nicht mehr gegeben, weil auch die Shuttles nicht mehr hinfliegen können. Und wenn man Hubble reparieren will, dann muss man das Ding irgendwie einfangen, muss es im Shuttle dann kurz fertig zwischenlagern, muss es reparieren, wieder aussetzen und wenn die Shuttles nicht mehr da sind, dann geht das nicht mehr. Irgendwann wird Hubble auch zu Ende sein. Der Nachfolger wird ja schon gebaut, das James Webb Space Telescope, das auch 2014, glaube ich, von der NASA gestartet werden soll. Und das ist natürlich auch, Hubble ist 20 Jahre alt, immer noch gut, aber im Vergleich mit dem, was man heute bauen kann, doch viel kleiner. Das James Webb Teleskop ist auch wesentlich größer als das Hubble Teleskop. Hubble ist so groß wie ein Schulbus ungefähr, das ganze Ding. James Webb Teleskop ist so groß wie ein Tennisplatz ungefähr, das gesamte Ding. Also da kann man einiges erwarten von dem Ding, wenn es mal gestartet ist.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich auch.
Florian, ich glaube, wir sind jetzt hier am Ende angekommen unserer Reise. Haben wir irgendwas ganz Entscheidendes vergessen?
Ach, das Universum ist groß.
Bei dem Thema kann man wirklich so aus dem Vollen schöpfen. Da muss man echt mal gucken.
Wir hätten noch über Enzytidus reden können, die Eisvulkane, und über Jo und die Feuervulkane. Muss ja nicht für die letzte Sendung gewesen sein. Möglichkeiten zu reden über Sonnensystemen, da könnte man tagelang reden.
Genau, deswegen ist es auch immer ein bisschen knifflig, den Fokus zu finden. Ich dachte, wenn man sich mal aus Sternensystemen ein bisschen Astronomie beschränkt, dann kann man schon eine ganze Menge rausholen. Das war jetzt auch schon wieder eine ganz ordentlich lange Sendung. Ja, vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Das war auf jeden Fall sehr aufschlussreich. Und ja, vielen Dank auch hier immer wieder fürs Zuhören. Für all die, die hier wirklich immer bis zum Ende durchhören. Ich habe immer den Eindruck, das sind die meisten. Aber ich wundere mich dann trotzdem immer wieder bei so viel Zeug. Du findest ja immer so wenig Zeit zuzuhören. Ich kann das gut nachvollziehen. Aber hier gibt es auf jeden Fall Abnehmer. Ja, das war es dann hier auch mit meinem Besuch in Jena. Jetzt geht es wieder zurück nach Berlin. Und dann werde ich auch mal zusehen, dass ich jetzt hier mal in der Zahl der Sendungen Chaos Radio endlich mal eingeholt bekomme. Das steht jetzt dringend an. Ja, nochmal vielen Dank. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.